Oh demons be gone be gone demons be gone
leave this studio leave this planet
leave our universe leave this is legit
sage from a Native American woman Wow
so we're purifying is wrong wonderful oh
you money but may owe money but may you
please God bless this room and Odin to
you just in case they were wrong
that's her eyes abandon Odin he was
around first you know you got to think
of all the gods that everybody believed
in and they're like I'm not so sure
about Thor yeah and then they let him go
what if Thor was legit right and he's
still out there just like somebody who
just pissed a lot of Fame as a god yeah
he's like don't you [ __ ] see the
lightning yeah that's me throwing bolts
he's like one of those guys and you go
to Vegas and you see one of those
billboards for a strange casino and
you're like oh that guy yeah Tony
Orlando and Dawn I remember them
Thor is it the Mirage I was doing a
residency you [ __ ] check out
the Thunder that's actually caused by
atmospheric conditions so no you [ __ ]
doors on cameo make that imagine who had
a someone had a really good point about
that some some atheists was arguing
against religions it might have been Sam
Harris probably with Sam Harris but
might even Richard Dawkins but he
basically said there's 99 different gods
that people who believe in the Christian
God don't believe it
and he goes atheist just take it one
step further hey just guys we just one
got away that's what he was saying
that's cool yeah there I get confused
with being an atheist all the time I
I do not believe I'm an atheist I I
believe I am I'm open to everything
person
I don't believe stories about people
coming back from the dead and I don't
because they're written by people right
yeah man I mean that's right and also
they're supposed to function on more
than the surface level they're supposed
to be a kind of fractal that has inside
of it a lot of like symbols related to
just human existence yes not they're not
meant to be so much like taken literally
that's when you embarrass yourself on
either side exactly on either side of
you that's a really good point it's in
the translations apparently are so
difficult to do yeah apparently the
trail especially Old Testament when they
translated the Old Testament they had to
translate it didn't think of all the
different languages it had to go through
it was Latin and Greek and German and
English and all these different
languages that are so different like if
you ever used the the translate button
like I follow a lot of Russian fighters
and they you know and their Instagram
feed they write in Russian always like
oh translate it's a really cool feature
you could but you could tell it's not
exactly what they meant because it's all
[ __ ] up because their language is
different right like the way they
structure sentences is different so
English doesn't just plug and play right
you know it's like sticking a USB 3 into
a USB a hey this doesn't really fit all
right now add time add thousands of
years and scrolls and my hangs wanted
things changed
yeah the King James Version it's the
best that's my favorite one to read on
acid that's one King James book a John
baby hit that on acid it's so wonderful
it's so trippy because it's like that's
when I really like Christianity clicked
for me regardless of its whether it's
real or not but that's when I was like
okay I get this because the book of John
when you read it you're like well
someone wrote it I don't know who wrote
it and you ever [ __ ] wrote this their
mind was blown man like this wasn't
written by someone who was just like a
normal person this is the person who was
freaking out in the most intense way and
so to me that's what I love about it is
it's like something about
the how old it is and the distortions
the historical distortions the warping
of it produce this kind of awesome
glitched out mosaic of if nothing else
human consciousness 5,000 years ago
where our minds were that's trippy by
itself regardless of whether or not a
person who could like raise the dead and
walk on water was walking about just
holy [ __ ] here's how people thought bad
yes yes yeah I mean all the stuff that
you can't prove you don't know that's
interesting it's weird it's weird that
where those stories came from and why
they're so universal like someone has to
everyone has like a creator everyone has
like a main dude that did the thing and
you know then there's some other people
that have like large groups of gods like
the Greeks had gods for everything the
Indonesia lot of Native Americans had
gods for everything or yeah yeah animism
it's it's like I've talked to people who
make who produce electronic music and
some of them say that the computers have
a life in them a sentience is spirit
inside their computer so there's a
collaboration happening it isn't
one-sided when they're making stuff it's
like working with like the spirit within
the machine which is pretty trippy man
like why do they but this is based on
input or the way they reacted that when
they're putting in the input to the
thing they think the things responding
to them yeah it's yeah they think that
there's a it's alive they're like
standard keyboards or there's just
electronic stuff I know someone who
makes visual art on their computer their
laptop that you end it like or you know
do you have an Alexa apart don't you
know echo like sometimes I'll realize
the way I'm talking to that thing is
like really impolite it's kind of fun
yeah it's fun to yell at robots yeah you
know it's really funny I made fun of
this but there is a point to this PETA
had a statement that they put out a
while back because these dudes from
Boston Dynamics were kicking the [ __ ]
out of these robots they're trying to
figure out they're trying to figure out
how to get these robots to fall over and
they're trying to make they're making
these insanely durable robots like
this if you take scientists and
engineers and you say hey I want you
guys here's a [ __ ] ton of money I want
you guys to make the dopest robots you
can make like they're gonna make robots
you can kick and it's not a living thing
so but PETA released some statement
saying they didn't see it's cool to kick
robots no it's real it's real it's real
what yes they would think I think the
statement I'm paraphrasing was something
to the effect of there's other things
that are more important but it's still
not cool to kick robots it just shows
you what will happen when robots become
alive because those [ __ ] traitors
those people this is people to think
that robots are alive and they're us
yeah those emotionless things that have
no place in our world with power they're
supposed to be things that we control as
soon as you let them control themselves
you try to pretend they're a person this
is gonna wipe it out yeah man can you
imagine I'm not gonna try to kick one of
those [ __ ] DARPA BOTS they're
terrified they would have a record of it
they would always remember that this one
kicks robots it's in the cloud yeah and
then they'll show it to you one day and
some super sophisticated genius god
robot sits you down on the couch and
shows you you kicking these unbeknownst
to you sentient robots yeah they were
just trying to [ __ ] figure out what
am i what am i I'm like a bait they were
like little babies and you're kicking
them robots the robots are very very
upset at you in the future
they might just reanimate your ass and
just show you over and over that clip of
you kicking the [ __ ] yes do you see what
Trump tweeted now he tweeted and deleted
it's [ __ ] hilarious
he said checks are coming to everyone in
America except the people who used
hashtag not my president I wouldn't want
to offend you with a check from someone
that's not your president to do that
effect see if you can find that oh and
then it would hatch tag maggot
afterwards I mean he just dunked on them
the president dunks on people yeah
tweet the leader is someone whose
Department was probably like mr. Trump
that's not a good idea they have a siren
that goes off
got it with that yeah I know the
president can delete tweets how much is
he gonna send I think I think they
wanted to give like a thousand dollars a
month or something like that to
Americans is that the idea Jeremy it's
hurt lots of things I don't know up to
2000 and a Bernie Sanders should give
2,000 a month
gotta be 2000 everybody but if you give
everybody $2,000 a month it's a good
thing but everyone's gonna go hey you
could have done this the whole time
that's right
what do you wait a minute if you just
raise taxes can you just give people
money can just give people more money
and if I'm not saying we should do this
but imagine that was a solution to all
this if you just give people more money
over they just sort of levels out and
relaxes and Rob's drug abuse drops well
I mean they've got to know that when
people don't have work they don't have
money with no money they can't support
their family that's when the riots start
yes that you just catch on fire they
know that to the it's like a bribe to
try to keep people from rioting until
whatever the [ __ ] wars past you can look
at it that way or it's giving people a
different environment to exist in one
that doesn't leave them hostile so
instead of looking at it like a bribe
look at it like you don't want I see
what a lot of your problem is we're not
you're not asking for affluence you
could barely get by but if it was easy
to get by if you could just get by and
then you could pursue other things would
that be better for society and that was
like what Andrew yang was suggesting if
this whole automation revolution took
place and everything started getting
automated and no one had a job anymore
there might be something to that there
might be something that now even you
know the question is like what are what
are you happy your your taxes get used
for you know it's almost like you should
be able to vote on that like the one
thing that we don't get real direction
on right like in terms of like what the
country actually wants but if we could
all just individually vote on things
like that like where's where's my taxes
go all right my taxes to go 100 percent
to education right I want to make that
cut and you know you guys get a figure
out
what to do with the rest of the money
maybe he did that money I wanted to go
towards education but then nobody there
the people who would be paying for war
and prisons and [ __ ] would just be like
BDSM people how about the salaries how
about the salaries of politicians how
about the money then we go tours private
jets yeah it's [ __ ] crazy also like
the loose connection between the state
and corporations the way it's just all
kind of merging together right now and
also you know it appears to be kind of
the apocalypse at the moment like well
it's it's if it's not the apocalypse I
don't think it's the apocalypse I think
it's just a dangerous dangerous illness
but it's definitely a dress rehearsal
it's a dress rehearsal for [ __ ]
people gonna become Preppers it is gonna
be amazing for the toilet paper industry
they're gonna they're gonna experience a
banner year they say you got toilet
paper stock you're riding high right now
do you remember the I don't know if you
if you had this experience but like I
can remember sitting at my computer and
pressing the button on Amazon where I
wanted to buy something and it's like
this isn't available right now it's my
button that brings me things
it didn't like suddenly just realized oh
my [ __ ] god how completely weak have
I become
that I got accustomed to pressing this
button and people would bring groceries
to my house yeah and now they don't now
it's like stopped not only that I'm so
accustomed to like well you know I'll
just go to the grocery store and pick up
some food it's always been there it's
not there dude I had an insta cart
delivery today
you know cuz we wanted to get stock up
on food Oh two hundred dollars worth of
food guess what I got
strawberries hummus and I think we got
like I don't know some like eggs that's
it out of the whole order everything
else was sold out all the beef gone all
the chicken gone nothing's there
it's like the the shelves are empty so
it's like okay send everybody to
thousand dollars a month but what are
they gonna buy if there's like no food
on the shelves like well I think that
was a temporary freakout where people
stockpiled stuff and I think as long as
food keeps getting delivered on a normal
schedule
I think that'll normal out I hope I did
I do
I think that'll normal out but it just
shows you there's so many things in our
society that are amazing like grocery
stores like cell phones like we can call
each other all this too but those things
are so fragile yeah they like they're
they're so vulnerable like if an
emergency happens and everyone wants to
call it once the cell phone system can't
handle it yeah like it's not like you
have a phone and you can call any time
you want and I have a phone I call any
time I want and everyone in the world is
a phone they can call any time they want
know if everybody does that the system
is not set up to handle that's right if
everybody does it like ah like that's
why if there's an earthquake or tsunami
everyone's [ __ ] it's so hard to make
phone calls yeah it's not gonna get
through yeah well dude I just heard on
NPR that so many people were requesting
unemployment that it's crashed systems
in several states that's because this is
a real problem one of my friends was
saying he's like you know a lot of
people are running out of money tomorrow
they're bartenders anyone in the service
injure all the people who work at the
Comedy Store
yeah it's not like I mean how many of
them had a lot of money like stored up
none of them so what what happens now
when there's no food on the shelves we
gotta help them where I've been a text
message thread with Whitney Cummings and
Nick Swardson and Chris D'Elia and we're
talking about that very thing right now
I kind of do it and how to set up a fund
it needs to be done for sure you know
people that can help should help this is
not a normal time this is not a time
where people are lazy this is a time
where the whole world got [ __ ] real
quick yeah and weren't ready for it and
we're gonna have to come together but
this is a good time for people to
recognize the importance of community
it's a terrible time for Humanity it's a
terrible time for us and terrible time
for the people that are sick but it's a
really good time for us to understand
why community is important
we live in this illusionary world that's
provided to us by the culture that we've
created where you can just buy things
anytime you want you don't need people
you come home you watch Netflix you
don't engage with anyone you get in your
car you barely say hi to anybody at work
we're detached from each other and this
is the only time ever in life
we've been detached from each other and
we're being detached by these goddamn
electronics yeah they're sneaking up on
us
yeah electronics and cars which is also
you know it's a it's also a creation a
mechanical creation and now more than
ever they're driving computers yeah man
it's true what I'm trying to say is Ted
Kaczynski was right oh my god we all
know that he was right do you ever read
his manifesto no I'm scared it's catchy
that's I went through a period of like
doing ketamine and like trying to watch
the worst thing I like it Charles Manson
Kaczynski and yeah it is you know it is
a little bit like kind of interestingly
not that off but then the tone is so
Imperial or something when you're eating
it there's like this it's a manifesto
that's I have to write it you know but
the one thing my wife is part of like
it's not like it's called a mommy group
so it's like a connection of online of
all these mommies and like all over LA
and what they do is they post people
will post [ __ ] they need so like one of
the moms just had a kid they don't have
any wet wipes and so then all the other
moms would like oh we've got wet wipes
and then right now they're just leaving
them on the door so people come and get
them so it's like I think the community
thing is exactly right also people have
to maybe transcend money for a second
and figure out ways to set up in their
community like what do you need what do
I have and then start some form of like
trade or just giving people you know
there was someone who set up a toilet
paper exchange I don't know in LA where
he was just like if you have extra
toilet paper bring it and then he had
toilet paper and you're just giving it
out to people who are you know that's I
think that's the sort of thing we're
gonna have to start doing if we can you
know is like right now there's old
people who they they're the key to [ __ ]
I can't do anything they're terrified
they can't even get online if you know
them you got to help them and this is
you know this is a weird time for us but
it's a time for us to reset you know
it's not it's not good I'm not saying
it's good but I'm saying there's a we
can get a positive out of this yeah
people that make through the people that
make it through we can get a positive
out of this and the positive is
community is important it's really
important and it seemed like it wasn't
important because it seemed like we had
everything set up so you didn't have to
engage with people it's not the right
way to do it it's not good for anybody
now that kind of life is not good and
the detachment that we have I mean
that's why why do you think people have
road rage on the highway you know when
they're locked in their little box
separated from people in a way that they
but they wouldn't have it in person yeah
it was just I mean it's only a thin
piece of metal and glass separating you
from these people
yeah there's not with that there's the
other added factor of the heightened
senses because you're driving fast you
realize you might have to make quick
movements so dumb things people do are
elevated and they're even no more dumb
yeah but it's also that you're detached
you're you're in these boxes right it's
like a weird dream we've done weird [ __ ]
to each other yeah because of that we're
all gummed up in that way it's like
something it's like it's like a fungus
that grew on the circuitry of society
and starting or it's like you know when
they talk about the dolphins and the
whales being [ __ ] up by the high-tech
sonar they're using and washing up on
the beach because the sonar is messing
up their ability to communicate with
each other it's like there's this kind
of technological sonar that is
completely made us disconnected from the
earth essentially like our earth
connection has been replaced by a
technological connection now the
technology comes from the earth but
we're talking about a secondary thing
can compare it to you know your feet
touching the ground you know being
around another human and like
recognizing them as having exactly the
same thing you have which is they want
to be happy you know feeling the
connection between people when you're
with someone I mean I don't know if
you've ever done that but just like the
next time you're around anybody that
you're like buying [ __ ] from or that you
don't normally just kind of go by
feel like that connect you can feel it
there's an energetic connection that you
can feel there that's easy to overlook
yeah we we've lost the biggest one which
is through light pollution I think every
night people were humbled and reminded
of the majesty of the universe when they
looked up and saw the infinite skies on
a clear night yeah the infinite star is
just the whole Milky Way you could see
the whole thing yeah you know and
there's parts of the country where
there's plenty of darkness and you could
literally see the whole Milky Way and it
makes you think like Oh our ancestors
saw this [ __ ] freaky [ __ ] all the
time we decided to shut off the greatest
art the world has ever known because we
want to be able to see better at night
yeah the greatest art and art that
literally not not just as inspired
Science and Wonder - and fueled it right
but also as kind of always put people in
place always just just understand this
is not a backdrop it's not a tapestry
that up there is madness it's forever
and you're not protected there's just a
thin layer of gas between you and the
universe which is infinite you're this
tiny little speck of nothingness in this
impossible to understand spans of
planets stars it just goes on forever
literally forever and we're one little
tiny piece of it and we're being held
here with a spin and some air and
there's a giant [ __ ] fireball in the
sky that keeps us alive it's a million
times bigger than the earth yeah and
it's right there and this is this is the
reality that we live in
it is almost too crazy to put in your
consciousness on a daily basis so we
forget about it all the time it's the
one of the most important things about
our existence here is it we're a part of
the universe yeah it's not just that
we're in you know [ __ ] Sherman Oaks
or we're hanging out in Montana no we're
right there connected in the universe
and it doesn't get brought up and one of
the reasons because we don't see it we
don't [ __ ] freak out you
if you order the country you're camping
you [ __ ] freak out you're like wow
you see the stars like this is [ __ ]
nuts man you can see them all it's it's
a reset button it changes how you feel
about life yeah yeah well also seems
like a lot of us have forgotten that
we're gonna die on top all that I mean
yeah not only are you like looking up at
this void filled with stars but the
thing you are is temporary and that to
me is you know the other day I'm like
just washing dishes during this [ __ ]
pandemic and I'm thinking to myself man
I feel so lucky to be washing dishes
right now I'm alive I'm healthy
[ __ ] it was a different kind of
washing dishes than a week ago when I
was able to or two weeks or before that
[ __ ] started when I could order anything
I [ __ ] wanted off the internet it
suddenly I'm in a different world like
this is a world where well we got to
wash these dishes because man if I get
like if bugs come I don't know if I want
to call an exterminator right now I
don't know how many people I want in my
house right now I don't know what this
[ __ ] is so it's like suddenly these are
what you're experiencing is this kind of
like well what does it say in the Bible
that we both love so much fear of the
Lord is the beginning of wisdom and I
think you could easily translate that to
understanding your place in the universe
should produce a kind of positive fear
and trembling not like you're anxious or
terrified right but just a kind of like
whoa this doesn't last nothing about
this last and right now everyone around
the planet is getting a first-hand
glimpse of that very truth right yeah
all at once one big dose one big dose of
it all at once one big dose are people
to recognize how much of what they
concentrate on a daily basis how much
what fills their consciousness is [ __ ]
it's utter nonsense yeah when we got
tricked we got tricked into thinking it
would go on forever and now we know it's
not going to and now we know hey look
this is a this is a terrible thing but
relatively speaking
compared to supervolcano asteroid impact
compared to something Solar Flare
something really crazy that can happen
and blow out all the power yeah which is
a hundred percent of possibility solar
flares are 100% a possibility and for
people did not recognize that and just
go through their life it's just because
we we we look at life as if what we've
experienced while we're alive is the
norm but it's not it's not the norm it's
just hard for you to recognize that your
life is so short your life is so short
that when they're measuring all the
different catastrophes that have
happened over the earth whether it's
proven sites of asteroid impacts or
proven sites of volcano eruptions or all
these different things that have
happened for sure and wiped out millions
of people all over the world they happen
over a timespan that's too big our head
doesn't get in there a head doesn't go
what what is thirty thirteen thousand
years is just some scratches on some
paper in my head my stupid head I don't
know what thirteen thousand years means
I can't I can't do it but thirteen
thousand years ago they think and
there's more and more evidence every day
that there was some big impact on earth
yeah and who who [ __ ] knows how many
of those humans have gone through who
knows for the the what I think
scientists believe what is it it's like
three hundred thousand plus years we've
been this right is it the idea Homo
Sapien something like that right brother
Nate [ __ ] that's so short that's so
short just in the time that the the
earth has been here in the four point
whatever billion years the earth has
been here and that's so short in terms
of the almost fourteen billion years the
known universe has been here all of its
madness every single step along the way
is madness but we get stuck in these
little time periods where nothing
changes and so we think that this is
life so we've built all these houses
that only can work on electricity how
many [ __ ] people have a real
fireplace in their house that live in
cold places
banning those now so if they're banning
fireplaces because they don't want to
start fires that's great as long as you
can ensure the gas and the power is
gonna stay on and I don't think you
could do that yeah I think you can
because you've done it for a hundred
years that's right that's the thing
hundred years this shit's a hundred
years the Industrial Revolution the
roaring 20s from from then to today Oh
let's go 150 let's get crazy that ain't
[ __ ] yeah that ain't [ __ ]
to say this is how things are every day
is so dumb it's especially to say within
terms of the earth natural disasters
space anomalies like not even anomalies
things that happen like solar flares
they have an all the time man yeah man
well I mean and we don't even know
that's other thing we don't know all
this um all the data in the universe we
don't know that there isn't something
called like a quadtree Xion ripple it
happens every you know 16 million years
this whole Sean Carroll right now I need
information you know do you know that
poem Ozymandias Ozymandias yeah no I
Shelley I think it's like I don't know I
memorize but the basically it's like
diploma is about someone who sees the
broken legs of a statue in the desert
and written on a plaque is my name is
Ozymandias ruler of rulers king of kings
behold my works ye mighty and despair
[ __ ] you think you have power who
think you have all this control it's
like we don't like I guarantee of course
like in ancient Egypt there was probably
I'm not talking about the Pharaoh but
there's at least like a thousand dudes
who are like I'm like the hot [ __ ] and
Egypt and they're gonna remember me for
a long time it's like we don't know you
are it's all gone eradicated wiped out
and this to me is like one of the really
side effects of this thing this
technology thing is we've all become
completely self-obsessed self-absorbed
putting our images out there making sure
that our profiles are updated making you
know what I mean like we have this
insane idea of like we're so deeply
rooted in our ident
instead of in the connections between
our identities they were all the only
way that we can finally see how
connected we are is some [ __ ]
eats a bat you know it's really crazy
man think of this if technology really
did have an effect on the programming of
human beings and the human beings
interacting with technology think we're
internet innocently interacting with a
non-sentient thing but all the while
this technology and and you could call
we get confused we think the technology
is like a digital clock or a television
or a computer it is but it's also like a
fish hook right like so the Sony it's
innovation so yeah someone had to figure
that out and imagine creating an ape
that is aware of its environment like
this is like really the perfect storm
aware of its environment but obsessed
with itself knows in the back of its
head that it's it's temporary that it's
a it's it's got a finite lifespan
but lives like it's gonna live forever
and lives in the moment lives in the
moment and wants to acquire things it
seems the number one goal for the you
know the uber wealthy or the uber
successful the Jeff Bezos types
characters right or on the top of the
food chain financially they want to
acquire things yeah they're always
acquiring things which means people have
to make things which means that they're
like they're a big consumer as well as
someone who's is making a [ __ ] ton of
money right and this also fuels
innovation because you got to keep up
with these people kind of keep giving
them bigger and better things every year
so it all this all these resources go
into innovation of technology it's the
thing that progresses quicker than
anything right look at cell phones every
year I need a hundred and fifty
megapixel camera or you're a loser
yeah you're a loser yeah you know these
[ __ ] Samsung phones that are like
seven inch screens now everyone's going
crazy right but
what is the goal though the goal is to
make better [ __ ] and the goal along the
way of like this goal is it's working
but you know be even better if we've
made it so they don't touch each other
anymore if we maybe if we could come up
with a disease where they can't shake
hands they don't they don't come close
alright and yeah just keep them a little
further apart from each other it'll make
them more interested in the things more
interested in the technology more more
separate from each other and encourage
technology that connects them with each
other so through technology they'll
they'll find this human longing for
contact that they were missing in their
life they're gonna get an emulated
version of it but that emulated version
of it just gonna keep getting better and
it's gonna keep getting better and it's
gonna get to a point where it's better
than real life way better than real life
because you like Jumanji you get to be
the rock you know you get to be the like
a superhero like in you could you could
live a magical life with no boundaries
of physics and that they're gonna do
that people are gonna do that they're
gonna give in if I was a life-form that
was trying to haunt another life-form
and trick it into giving birth to me
that's I would create a person I'd
create people people we put like some
[ __ ] ant
we're like some and that's manufacturing
our successors yes we are yeah and we
don't even know what we're doing just
showing up every day look at my [ __ ]
watches I got all these diamond chain
chain chain yeah like bling but just my
house is bigger than the rocks people
are doing this we're doing we're just
buying more [ __ ] and one good thing of
something like this anytime a tragedy
happens people bond together afterwards
it's a terrible thing that it happened
yeah but it for the victims and the
family members of the victims we all
know this but it it can be a good reset
for us economically people gonna have to
get through it that's gonna be the most
difficult part yeah but I think there's
there's gonna be an opportunity for us
to just assume a nicer stance towards
our neighbors and towards our friends
and towards our community and instead of
embracing this idea like better get guns
because they're coming
maybe we can all come together I think
people
need to find if there that's gonna
happen then we've got to find a better
metric for whether things are right or
wrong yeah in the news yes we need
something to retune ourselves like we're
right now we're tuning the guitar of our
identities to these two like the most
terrifying [ __ ] which is the news or
like what people are saying and so if
that's if and I think many people become
so accustomed to getting their idea of
what's happening in reality from the TV
instead of from like how they feel
inside what's going on with their
friends and their family that puts
people at incredible disadvantage yes
their pond is being rippled by [ __ ] you
know I was thinking it's like um
what are those little not prairie dogs
those they stand and look around at the
Hawks you know I'm talking about what
are those things called they're like
there are social little marmots or
something like oh no there is a show
like lemur palace I don't remember what
they're called something but they're
like they're like they're really cute I
see them at the zoo most one of the most
durable animals ever they stand and live
somehow they ignore all the humans
around them and just look in the sky for
a hawk it's kind of sad but that's their
life though but imagine if that one
looking for the hawk had like the
internet and could see Hawks thousands
of miles away how anxious all of them
would be because he would always be like
get on the ground get on the ground get
so you know I think this this is what
has happened is that we're all
constantly being told I mean I remember
when I was growing up in the old days
when the news had an alert that was
serious some serious [ __ ] with you
you'll be what the [ __ ]
Fox News or any of the news stations to
have an alert like every four minutes
now don't Adam alert alert and it's all
telling us just what you're saying get
underground go inside go inside danger
out here danger out here and so we're
all like even before this [ __ ] we were
huddled up a little bit now we can
rationalize the huddling you know and
that's what we're doing were just
huddling inside right now that's an
incredibly vulnerable place to be I mean
I'm not gonna get Conspirator
if I was the artificial intelligence and
I was about to hit the switch and become
sentient I would want to I would want to
remove the threat of human beings as
much as possible before I hit the switch
wait a minute and this is the best way
you make them sick I'm gonna have to
give birth make them they can get sick
confuse them keep them poor and then
boom it comes out of nowhere and then
what then they just start eating us
those were fuel they're not gonna eat
you know who came up with do you know
that was a that was a DARPA project what
EA T are robots there were robots that
survived on Biological air quotes
biological material so like maybe they
could eat plants or babies whatever's
around I need a friend at DARPA robots
that eat tissue this this is do robots
eat people not and it's a corpse eating
robot yes bro what yes well II hate it
playground call it literally will so
true look at it the colors it's
ridiculous it's like a kid's toy it
should look like a vulture it should be
like red and black like a vulture yeah
it should definitely be black red
lightning bolts on the side nice patina
like a ward out patina like it's just
going through the battlefield
eating bodies if you're not quite dead
and it starts chewing you feet first how
does it determine whether or not you're
dead what if you can make it what if he
just out cold
what if you got knocked out and it's
like a movie you wake up in the
battlefield and there's a bunch of
movies where that happens right guys
aren't really dead they just badly
injured these [ __ ] there's a
video right down below of us talking
about it [ __ ] terrified of those
things just the idea that someone made
something that can eat people that will
listen folks the technology that existed
in like early cell phones right like if
someone made an early Motorola phone
with a camera all that stuff got into
everything now you're there's so many
things that could take pictures now in
so many phones that can take pictures
one robot and one like proof-of-concept
where something could be fueled on dead
bodies
you don't think other people are gonna
make those two and you don't think
they're gonna get better they're gonna
get better and then when we do go to war
with the robots and this big giant
bulletproof metal ones just eating us
and using us as fuel we're gonna be like
what have we done what have we done
we've created a thing that eats people
and yeah even if it's just the baby
right now that thing could evolve to
become something that literally is the
thing of nightmares as Stephen King
movies who are we're just running around
looking for people eating people it's a
black mirror episode gone wrong man
alright I to me I just like to think
about the meeting where the guy was like
last night I woke up in the middle and I
like this idea
I got it y'all what if we make a robot
that devours corpses and somebody was
like you know what I kind of like that
Jake let's uh let's put 50 million into
that project see what we could do Jesus
yeah just imagine like this is the other
thing man is like we we somehow imagined
that that thing that made Genghis Khan
Genghis Khan is like now out of people
like there isn't somebody on the planet
right now that has the same ambition as
a warlord
you know we somehow forget that see I
just think people don't understand that
like there's this idea that the world
leaders are just you know humanists and
there have are you know the interest of
humanity is the first thing they're
thinking about when they wake up every
day we don't know that they're some of
them aren't interested in the same thing
every conquering warlord has been
interested which is like maybe we could
take over the planet I wonder if there's
a way and you know imagine if you ended
up President of the United States or
like President of Russia or president of
any powerful wherever you know maybe
when you're a high one night I don't
know if they get high but I would you
know or maybe when you're like just like
stinking wouldn't it flicker through
your mind kind of like I wonder if there
would be a way
to take over the world I wonder if
there's a way that I could become the
king of earth cuz you know when you look
up there in the sky I'm sure there's
many earths out there that have one king
one ruler someone who conquered the
entire planet someone who figured out a
way to do it to like just why couldn't
you that's the other thing I mean what's
stopping that from happening one day
there being one primary Authority some
Imperial Majesty we are all one Duncan I
know yeah if we were all one but we just
have to get rid of some of our laws
other people are not going to accept our
laws okay we just got to tighten that up
a little bit and we could have one ruler
of the whole plan yeah and we're gonna
fix everything by working together we're
gonna evenly distribute resources it's
gonna be better this way the resources
gonna have to give up all of your
privacy that's all but but through that
everyone's gonna be happier yeah are you
in or are you an outsider are you gonna
act like you're not in and if you act
like you're not in then we'll find
another way to hypnotize you because
we'll just pretend to be people who
aren't in you know and they'll trick you
will infiltrate yes yeah that's what
yeah that's what you do man that's like
that's the problem is like no matter
what revolutionary idea gets out there
that anybody has the contagion of the
revolutionary idea is easily warped and
twisted by people who have like other
ideas that run counter to that you know
like it's so easy to confuse people who
believe that Twitter Instagram CNN Fox
News Drudge Report Wall Street Journal
New York Times is an accurate metric of
what's happening on the planet
yeah that's not very many information
streams man right like how hard would it
be to infiltrate all the information
streams in some small way and gradually
start warping them so that people become
more open to the idea of being
constantly surveilled constantly
monitored and not speaking up about it
because if you speak up about it then
you're a conspiracy theorist I got
another way of looking at it that I've
been thinking
if it's just this is how life goes what
if instead of this being like some grand
conspiracy by the robots or by the the
elites what if this is just how systems
go
when one thing gets too big isn't in is
in too much power
there's no it's no longer a struggle to
survive its reached some stagnant point
biologically in some sort of weird way
and also maybe even without for lack of
a better word spiritually stagnant right
I mean some people are breaking through
and realizing who you know who they are
and their connection other people but
globally god there's a lot of people
that are sleep sleepwalking out there
sleepwalking hypnotized by technology in
society and this is this is their big
wake-up call right now what if this all
this even materialism right even our
obsession with technology maybe look if
you look at all the systems that exist
in the universe and particularly all the
biological systems that exist on earth
some of them are so spectacular you're
like what what happened here how did
they do this like have you ever seen
like leaf cutter ants when they take
their their buildings and they pour
cement in them and they realize these
fermentation chambers and the they
ferment the leaves in there there's air
holes out to the earth and there's all
these [ __ ] tunnels and this is crazy
elaborate city structure that's created
by these ants well there's all these
systems that that take place all over
the earth for if there's too much plants
than these insects involved there's too
many insects the plants evolved all
these things happen to sort of keep some
sort of a balance ideas that infect
people the dumb ones that are so
intoxicated think about what's the some
of the most intoxicating [ __ ] I mean
intoxicating meaning that you're not
even really getting pleasure out of it
but you can't look away it's like some
of the dumbest reality television right
right and the fear factor you're sitting
there with your mouth I'll be like hmm
and you get sucked in to this thing that
the earth is created to make you it's
not
people what if the what if the grand
conspiracy is it's not robots it's not
people its life is trying to get rid of
you life is making it easier to survive
which makes you soft as [ __ ]
which makes you compliant to anything
that keeps you in that sort of soft
comfortable state I don't want to ruffle
any feathers if they need to look you my
emails you let them yeah and all the
while it's just the world it's the
universe plotting against us because
there's too many of us and we [ __ ] up
we have too much power and we're
obviously doing [ __ ] to the earth that
we shouldn't be doing like what we're
doing to the ocean we're sucking every
fish out we're dumping in all our
[ __ ] straws yeah look at what we're
doing a fracking where people have to
move because they can't use their water
and like well it's an acceptable outcome
basically we don't need to rely on Saudi
Arabia anymore but you you poison these
people's air they have to move out of
their [ __ ] house their waters on fire
literally their waters on fire and maybe
life is like okay what do we got here
let's get a virus let's get them
addicted to technology let's get a virus
let's get them obsessed with themselves
let's make the predominant thing that
people spend their time on not reading
books not [ __ ] walking alone with
their thoughts but staring at these
pictures of other people's photos yeah
selfies and butt pictures and look at
how this guy does chest you ever do
trust like that sucked sucked into
looking at these [ __ ] videos and and
then when it's when it's decided you're
weak it starts sending in some more
problems boom here's a little bit of
this boom here's a little bit of that
yeah boom here's a new disease yeah boom
here's a tsunami boom here's a nuclear
reactor you can't shut down yeah and
then you try to figure out whether or
not we're gonna be able to use our
amazing intellect to bypass our own
biological switches that have us
connected to this [ __ ] life we have
a lot of weird dumb biological switches
that were put in place back when we had
to survive against incoming hordes of
soldiers and
we're in the Information Age now what we
need to do is be sustainable in case of
emergency which we're clearly not and we
need to realize that this is temporary
and we when a bad thing happens it makes
you realize that it makes you realize
like hey I thought everything was gonna
be fine forever it's not this is real
just like a movie or a book we're just
not prepared for it because we haven't
experienced it we're like this is a
once-in-a-lifetime event no it's a once
in our lifetime event our lifetime is
too small for us to really get a grip
yeah like it's a blink it's a blink and
this is just you know like you said
dress or so if anything it's a dress
rehearsal for death I mean you're gonna
that's up the thing is is like that
blink if you're an atheist which you
know I get that and I think there must
be some like deep do you know any
atheists that have done like a real blow
out psychedelic session now I know a
couple and those those are the most
puzzling to me because the guy people
have done like real blow out mushroom
sessions or blow out DMT sessions I
always think that they would leave the
door open to the impossible because it
is impossible and you experienced it
it's not like even if you're imagining
it I couldn't imagine that so how am i
imagining that how am i imagining
something in such incredible vivid color
and and detail and and knowledge and
love and all these different things the
experience in that state that state is
otherworldly the fact that that is
accessible at all I don't care if it's
through a molecule or through a yoga
session I don't care how it's accessible
if the fact that that's accessible at
all leaves open to me the I don't know
because I didn't know that that was a
thing so once I've experienced that I'm
like oh well all this flat plane of
existence that we take for granted that
we think this is this is everything
around us this is the whole environment
you have to worry out for this might be
just one [ __ ] stage on the radio dial
of experience right and of dimensions
that are interacting with us we just
don't have the senses to to tune in to
them and when you can for me at least it
leaves open the door for who the [ __ ]
knows who knows man I just the fact that
that's a thing
there's a okay so this is a trip this
this is very trippy so I got this book
called the Tibetan yoga of dream and
sleep well I feel like it's [ __ ] cool
but basically it's like it's form of
Tibetan Buddhism that invites you to
explore the difference between when you
think you're awake and when you're
dreaming and so basically the idea is
there isn't much of a difference there
like right now you're dreaming this
thing you call your human incarnation
it's like it is a dream and you know
like when people are dying they get all
delirious and [ __ ] they slide through
time you know like I don't know if you
ever been around a dying person but they
they like suddenly they're back in
Vietnam they're in the 50s
they're in the 30s where however
whatever their lifetime which means that
when you're dying you're gonna like spin
through time - meaning that this could
be you dying right now spinning back
with you but like in a dream so that
when you you know this is the main thing
about it is that when we die according
to this we we sort of spend like 39 days
I think it is in a place called the
Bardo which is essentially like what
it's like to have no body but still have
this like I this basically like your
karma your identity sort of propelling
you through and that that that's how you
like you get your next incarnation so
essentially like that's the what we're
dealing with here is so bizarre and
surreal that it easily could just be a
dream state that one of these vast a
eyes that already exists is having we're
just processors we're just being run
it's like running a simulation of a
pandemic or maybe this is a way that
like an AI gets polished like maybe
we're an AI that's being like polished
and taught through this process of
having a limited incarnation you've got
to have that so that there's a reason
for us to actually invest ourselves and
stuff like if we
your gods if we live for a million years
eventually we wouldn't have such a
passionate relationship I think with the
world anyone who's gonna it so you need
that to train the thing up so it takes
it seriously you have to put the setting
on mortal then you know then maybe you
just run a series of tests on the thing
you know you start run what is this what
have we made what does it do in a
pandemic and by it I mean the sum total
of all humans which is right now
disconnected it's like a malfunctioning
brain the Sonata you know what I mean
we're not connecting but if we were
being like sort of I don't know how you
put it groomed evolved intentionally
then every single moment in an
individual's life and in a planet the
planets the life of history could be
looked at as a training or an upgrade
this could be an operating system
upgrade this could be what an operating
system upgrade looks like in the
bio-computer that we exist in it looks
like a [ __ ] pandemic and that's
what's happening right now is we're
being like upgraded for some reason even
though it's terrifying and obviously
horrific you know we're being upgraded
and when you anyway the whole point is
man this thing that we're in right now
whether or not there's a god we just I
think an atheist gets to lean into the
idea that when they close their eyes and
breathe their last breath it stops and I
just think that's a big gamble man
that's and I don't mean because you're
go to hell I mean how nice would that be
yeah if it just stopped when more than
likely it's you know the at least in
this Tibetan yoga of dreaming and sleep
more than likely what happens is way
before you actually die when you get
really sick you already start waking up
into your next life you just wait you
just like go through a weird dreamlike
stay called the Bardo where you freak
the [ __ ] out and then you're suddenly
alive and another being completely
oblivious to whatever your past
incarnations were and not to or in right
now so you know I don't know this is a
great time for people to start you know
looking at that in one in preparing for
that we didn't prepare for the [ __ ]
pandemic we didn't prepare some of y'all
did I'm sure but
there's a few Preppers out there
listening oh yeah who's ready I know you
guys did it man
you were right congratulations I've got
[ __ ] hummus and strawberries and some
like and but but I think that like also
preparing for like the authentic
apocalypse which is when you kick the
[ __ ] bucket yeah because the idea is
you know and this feel feel free to like
the goddamn sage again but the idea is
begone thank you
the idea is that you can actually like
navigate through that Bardo State you
can have a little bit of lucidity
instead of sort of dying and like
freaking out because it's a
hallucinatory state you could actually
have a kind of like I don't know focus
through it and control your next
incarnation yeah we just have to figure
it out that's the thing and when you're
young particularly if you're young you
don't have a lot of guidance which was
me when I was younger it takes a while
to figure it out because you're just
running on your own right there's no
you're not getting like a lot of
direction to how to live your life and I
moved around a lot too which really
didn't help but as you get older you
start getting a better sense of what
makes sense and what doesn't make sense
and what's important what's not
important what [ __ ] up your life and
what enhances your life but you don't
live long enough to really get it down
see if these these people like David
Sinclair or Aubrey de Grey all these
anti-aging geniuses that are out there
that are working on all these solutions
to extend human life favor really nail
it
they really nail it you know if David
Sinclair comes up with something and you
can live a hundred and fifty two hundred
fifty years by the time you're 150 years
old you're gonna have so much less
[ __ ] in your life you could have
realized like when you're thirty you'll
date crazy people you'll have more on
friends that you have to bail out of
jail you'll have these prompt but when
you get older you start going look I see
what's good for me and I see what's not
good for me you know and I see this some
people that are not willing to change
and they try they're not trying to do
better right they're just consistently
making the same mistakes over and over
again and dragging everyone down around
them you just got to move on from people
like that in your life when you're 150
man
could it be tolerating anything you're
just gonna just get it only have cool
people that you hang out with and and
will attract each other and then we'll
be able to work together on things right
knowing that each other are sane and
rational and are looking at these things
honestly they're not talking from a
position of trying to convince you of
their virtue or trying to talk you in a
position of doing something that'll
benefit them financially they're doing
it just because they're they're just
being in the moment and honest and being
a human being yeah man I mean you
basically just described like the secret
societies I mean you don't need to come
up with our own which we call it the
Illuminati no that's too much well you
know that if we came up with our own
right now what do we call it whatever it
is don't do initials man I hate that
just not good that can use those against
you yeah I don't know what do we call it
Jamie children of Jamie you know you
know but the thing is like these
immortal beings that you're talking
about they do already exist but they
exist as like communities that have
lineages attached to them so it's like
because our physical bodies die
we don't get to do the thing you're
talking about we roll when you're older
you do do that naturally and plus when
you have kids it's like you're just on
time for [ __ ] anymore there's no
time to [ __ ] around with somebody who's
like constantly [ __ ] up their life
you used to get drinks where they're
like you have a child and you have to
but we regardless there already is set
in place in on the planet these like
lineages there's essentially chains of
transmission in martial arts right look
when you look at a martial art you're
seeing a living being you know that as
it has its roots I don't know how far it
goes back when you look at yoga that's a
living thing that's transferred from
person to person so I think these things
already
immortality already does exist it just
doesn't exist in as a human and also
sometimes when I hear about these
technologists trying to live forever I
get a little scared thinking that's kind
of like you know if you could
theoretically do it you might be locking
yourself in a dream
it's worse yeah maybe can't die
you can't die you've you engineers some
polymer skin that's made of that spider
silk blend that they were trying to come
up with it's stronger than steel
yeah remember they were doing that there
they were there was an article about
them trying to create some sort of
bulletproof skin by engineering it with
spider silk yeah I remember that well if
that becomes what if that's real what if
they figure out a way to make people
completely invulnerable and we live
forever and then we hate it and we
didn't realize that if we just shut the
lights out we'd go to the next stage and
the next stage is amazing maybe that's
like the big trick the big trick is like
how do you how do you use this life and
how does it take you into the next stage
imagine if that's really what's
happening that's why every single look
I'm not saying that this means anything
but every single religion has someplace
you go when it's over yeah don't they I
mean almost all of them yeah I mean
that's an overlying theme now you could
say well that's just engineered to
provide comfort to people because you
know they want to feel like this life
means something but the reality is the
lights just shut off and to that I say
mainly I say mainly maybe but have you
have you ever been whacked out of your
mind on psychedelics cuz if you are you
would you would go who the [ __ ] knows
because that's a who the [ __ ] knows
moment so maybe death is a who the [ __ ]
knows mom maybe that's why every single
religion has these stories not every
single one but like look I mean there's
a lot of religions that people clearly
just made up right and we know the
people that made them they count too
they don't even have to pay taxes yeah
so let's not get holier-than-thou with
the concept of religions right so
there's a lot of really dumb religions
that probably don't have an afterlife
but it's just some [ __ ] that people made
up all of it but how many people have
made up this idea that there's a place
you go that's better than this yeah I
mean it's not just to make you
incentivize you to be good and to be a
good person or is it like an inherent
understanding of how the universe works
it might be both things it might might
be also be manipulative because you can
get people to comply with social norms
and society's rules if you tell them
that if they don't that God is watching
them and he will
mic them down and burn them forever that
is a way that is part of a way but it's
not gonna stop people from doing most
[ __ ] it's just not it never has you know
some of the most horrific things ever
done by human beings were done in the
name of Christianity right or and many
other religions but that but there is
something to the the possibility that
it's both things that it's an
understanding that when you do good in
this life you will you will go forth
into the next stage in a better place
right you'll feel better you'll be it
would be less less burdened by the past
you'll be less hampered by the failures
of your your ability to adjust the
ability to live a harmonious life with
people here on earth this there might be
something that's real and also the other
ideas you're it's not like this place
that they're talking about in religions
is existing after you die the idea is
like you're there right now
you just can't you're wearing a
blindfold that looks like your body mmm
and you in your life you're wearing a
blindfold that looks like your existence
you're behind and that's why the there's
always these stories of like Jesus
healing a blind man or like there's Paul
on the road to Damascus being like
blinded there's all these stories of
being like already existing in what
Buddhism some forms supposed to call
fundamental goodness that's already
where we're at that's the main channel
but we've sort of grown like little bits
of grass into the time-space continuum
and right now we're like waving in the
wind of our karma and not not realising
there's a beneath us or through us or
moving through us is a much grander more
beautiful incredible thing so like I
think when people say yeah they invented
it so people be afraid
it sort of imagines that these people
are having one-way conversations with it
you know that when they pick up the
phone it's just themselves they're
talking to you it's not imagining that
when people connect to this divine
source it immediately says oh ha yeah
this is the part of your program where
you were supposed to start remembering
what's really going on here and
reconnecting with me don't worry don't
feel bad
it's okay everyone goes through that in
fact you requested a disconnect for the
last 15 years when you're getting
hammered and imagining your Charles
Bukowski or whatever like if this was
all part of the plan
that was actually teaching you what
happens when you don't take care of your
body now
I'm we're like connecting sending a
download to you letting you know hi it's
us we're here we're not mad at you how
could we be we're infinite we've been
here since before the stars you wanted
this to happen my apologies for cutting
off your ball killing your mom and your
dad Jesus you know what I mean but
whatever this is all part of a bigger
thing and I think that's to me what God
is it's this constantly rejuvenating
synchronistic perfection that becomes
increasingly perfect and it exists
simultaneous to this seemingly imperfect
universe and it's always there for you
to connect to at any moment and when
people smoke DMT certainly that's one of
the avenues and that's a beautiful thing
so I think the reason for it is not to
scare people it's more so that people
who come like fountains for that and in
some small way become little droplets or
like divine bits of perspiration
bubbling up and into this place so that
folks who are really freaking out right
now are worried or scared or
disconnected could have at least the
chance to reconnect because listen man
if I was God wanting to get blasted if I
was some Divine Being wanting to get
high and Alan Watts has a beautiful
lecture on this I really do think at
some point I would want to cut off all
connection to the realization of my
divinity and experience infinite
lifetimes and it's on a planet and a
tumultuous planet and experience every
incarnation and all of it to get an
understanding of what it is like to be
extremely limited and what would this do
just add to my data banks it would just
help me increasingly become more and
more beautiful and perfect which seems
to be what we're in right now it's like
we have a limited data set based on our
neural neurology we can't see
certain colors we can't hear certain
sounds we don't know what happened
20,000 years ago we don't know what
happens five seconds from now and so
this is a perfect place to be in what's
becoming to know what it is to become
and to be limited and this is who knows
man is just something sniffing data you
know it's something just like you know
it's like snorting our lives like the
universe is snorting our lives on on
time and in the mirror of time well it's
the big thing right that keeps us from
seeing that the one thing that all
psychedelics have in common is the
dissolving of the ego they all dissolve
the ego what's that word dissolution
yeah dissolution dissolution of the ego
that what's happening with all of them
is it removes all this nonsense
narrative in your head everyone's ego
has this nonsense view of the world
that's based on them being the most
important thing and that you know all
the [ __ ] that they're thinking about
right now is of the utmost importance to
be done right now that's why people run
red lights you can't even wait you can't
even wait you [ __ ] it's one thing if
it's a medical emergency kids being born
so he's got a broken leg and you just
you got to get to the hospital right
away
I get it a hundred percent get it but
there's some people that just want to be
they just want to make that left turn
they don't give a [ __ ] of the light
change they want to cut in front of you
make that turn even block traffic
because they think more about themselves
and they do about other people and
that's that's a side effect of this life
that's been set up but it's almost like
maybe that's how it works maybe the life
creates challenges when there are no
challenges and the challenges are it
just starts to diminish you tries to see
if you're paying attention tries to
weaken you and make you stupid and turns
you into a [ __ ] zombie if you walked
into any restaurant any restaurant
during lunchtime and you see people on
their phones it's like this is bonkers
this is if this was anything else that
where half the room was using us an
electronic and staring into it for long
moments at a time not interacting with
the person across from them like that
becomes almost the norm they're like at
least 50% of the people and everyone's
interrupting everybody like you know
they're all just barely paying attention
to each other
well they haven't developed a muscle I
mean yeah it's a muscle you you it's
people just assume that the ability to
have a conversation is a natural part of
being an adult but it's like you I think
that's a true thing and a lot of people
to the point now where I just try to be
you know is I guess is like I just have
lowered my expectations yeah to the
point of like I don't know how many
people can pay attention that much and I
know I'm certainly distracted but
doesn't it feel [ __ ] weird even if
you're just watching TV with somebody
and they pull their phone out and start
looking at it it's so weird it's like
it's like the energy immediately down
[ __ ] yeah the moment it's like if you're
watching a movie with someone and
they're over there on their phone like
come on
yeah watch the goddamn movie with me
yeah even though we're not talking
designating we're not connecting it's
weird it's weird even fights he watch
fights with your friends they're on
their phone all dumb it's like are you
not even watching these fights you can
feel it yeah that's what you know the
Denver Comedy Works they've got the days
you don't know you know so like I was
listening do you ever listen to an
audience that doesn't have access to
their phones before a show there's so
mad do what no this no it's they talk to
each other yeah it's like it's like the
sound is better it's a better sound out
there it's a different murmur than a
phone murmur from you're out so yeah I
don't know man I think that I think life
presents all sorts of adversity and some
adversity doesn't feel like adversity
it's sneaky and that's what cellphones
are that's what technology is that's
certainly what so some social media is
you only realized what social media
truly can do when it comes at you you
know you get cancelled or there's a
bunch of people or tweet and mean stuff
to you then you realize like all these
horrible feelings this feeling of being
attacked by this thing that's been
grooming me oh yeah it's like what is
that like well if if the earth was
trying to get rid of us if the earth had
decided that there's an infection that
doesn't think it's an infection it
thinks it's so important that
should be allowed to pollute everything
around it should be allowed to scab up
the earth with giant concrete bandages I
mean that's what we're doing we're
putting these things everywhere that
cover up all the ground displace all the
life and then we shut off the light so
we can't recognize that we're in space I
mean the whole recipe is perfect yeah
it's perfect for charming us to sleep
the every every aspect of it the ego
part the the you know the fact that it
exists the fact that we have this
biological imperative to stay alive and
breed and then keep our DNA alive and
there's all these things that are set
into you to make sure that that happens
all the while where you recognize you
definitely are a finite life-form right
but yet you do something you hate every
day yeah you just keep doing it yeah I
mean you do something you don't enjoy
and you know when you get into
reincarnation which I love that thing
you're doing that you don't enjoy you've
been doing that for infinite lifetimes
it's that's called your clashes it's
you're sort of it's like underneath your
identity
it's basically your code it's it's your
tendencies I guess is the way you put it
so like you know if you have the
tendency to lose your temper then that's
something that you've been dealing with
for infinite lifetimes in it never ever
goes away until you start waking up
because the idea is to just go from
being this set of conditioned responses
reactions to your environment to being
something that's like lucid living you
know if you wanted to lucid dreaming try
lucid living you know which is the
practice I would say of like first under
what are your habituation you know what
like the other day I was sitting on the
couch I took my sock off and I spun it
like a lasso and threw it across the
room and my wife looks at me she's like
what what was that I'm like oh my god
holy [ __ ] that's how I've been taking my
socks off for years
and I didn't even know it I pull them
off lasso him and sling and like you
like that just that little thing I
didn't even know is doing something so
probably doing that since I was a kid
like I probably saw some cool kid lasso
it sucks and throw it I'm gonna start
[ __ ] lasso on my socks but like how
many other things are you doing that are
just like that they're just pure
habituation pure reactivity and this is
where you run into some scary [ __ ] man
which is what jaron lanier god i wish
you could get him on you know that guy
is what say his name jaron lanier
I feel like I've heard that name he is
what does he do
he's a thirty like developed all this VR
technology he's was in Silicon Valley
and it's when it was just starting
working on VR before the technology was
even there to have VR goggles he was
like building I think he liked and
helped his group helped build I think it
might be the oculus rift I'm sorry fans
of his out there you're upset I don't
know but some VR system yeah he's and
he's like his he's written a lot of
great books one of them twelve reasons
to get out or ten reasons to get off
your social media now really yeah I
wrote a book called uh yep
Jaron Lanier Jerry Aaron linear freaking
brilliant human man but um you know it's
called a ten or twelve kara twelve
reasons to get off your social media now
or delete your account something like
that there's a book of his I like better
than that called the dawn of the new
everything but and that's just him sort
of like talking about what it was like
working in Silicon Valley back then and
his sort of opinions on on this stuff is
a white guy with dreadlocks yeah yeah no
I think me body but um is me body well
his physical appearance there was a
large fellow [ __ ] brilliant
I believe it I said man there's a lot of
brilliant people with wacky hair yeah
yeah finding him because I'm like a I'm
nerdy doing I love him we do as those
bagpipes
what's happening with this guy he's
playing pipes who cares he's a genius
I don't care okay this is quite a few
photos of him with pipes goddamn it I
didn't see the pipe photos you cares
we should say like the kind you blow on
like flutes and pipes and white guys
with dreadlocks with their eyes closed
playing the flute it's a very few things
in life that make me feel like people
media - yeah my that's my guy here's a
new flute is amazing at it nothing wrong
with what he's doing I think it's
amazing I wish I could play a flute
[Laughter]
flute sound cool and I'm not being
disingenuous I'm not being sarcastic
flute sound cool I wish I got what is
that thing though that needs to go away
he's in the movie The Hobbit he's in the
[ __ ] pub and he's playing that thing
in the back because they haven't figured
out real music yet I'm only joking
I appreciate your contributions I'm just
joking I'm sure you were brilliant
Duncan's one of my favorite people if
he's brilliant just joking
look you if you want to listen you play
the flute the kind of people that are
like super intelligent and what whacked
out on you know technology I think
something like the flute would be an
amazing way to decompress right on the
organa mean you're literally using your
body to make a sound with air and tubes
he plays it's amazing he said he plays
like a hundred instruments or something
she was some kind of genius but he
here's the scary thing he said which is
if like BF Skinner is right and you know
pretty much if you can control the
things environment you can control it
this is the reason to be terrified of AI
because
you know the more advanced an AI gets
like you know where our assumption is
the things gonna eat us or kill us or
whatever it might just gradually
hypnotize us and buy and hypnotize us by
creating more and more enticing things
that grab our attention
hacks our neurology and begins to like
just do things that are completely
impossible to not look at and that you
know when you're saying an AI you know
advise the pandemic what if that you
know that how do you look away from a
pandemic mm-hmm
all of our nervous systems right now are
completely fixated on every tremor every
ripple every little data point that
flies across our screens we are so
absorbed in it right now we are locked
in like cats chasing laser pointers and
that is what he said we should be most
afraid of is that this these things
eventually could get to the point of
completely grabbing us and what you were
saying earlier is kind of maybe that's
what already happened maybe there's a
that is a process yeah maybe it's a
process that's not even put in place by
anything other than life itself the life
itself has these system setups no one
thing ever totally dominates and when it
does they find ways into it and then
it's this constant state of chaos that
produces better and better life forms
right that's what it is I mean if you
want to admit or you want a state that
we are better than our ancient ancestors
the you know the pre Homo Sapien
hominids I I think we're better I think
we're better they might have been
stronger than us but we've created more
overall as a species I think it's better
to be a person that it is to be a pre
person right I think as it goes on and
on we're gonna think the same way I
think the next stage of existence is
gonna be so happy it's not a person
running around letting their dick think
for them and [ __ ] getting drunk all
the time and crashing their motorcycle
and you know all the dumb [ __ ] that
people do all of the dumb [ __ ] from
alcohol and drug abuse
it's [ __ ] up relationships to
everything we do to lying and stealing
and being selfish
all that [ __ ] we'd be so happy if that
all went away oh my god those dude the
pre humans used to eat each other's
babies they were always [ __ ] stealing
and robbing they couldn't talk things
she couldn't express love who the [ __ ]
would want to be that right and then the
humans the humans were so full of [ __ ]
they were all addicted to their phones I
didn't even see it coming the phone
snuck in their life they welcomed them
with new versions every year paying for
their own demise yeah happily and they
were all angry and bitter and mean and
jealous and [ __ ] thoughtless and
polluting and then the next stage came
along and they eliminated all that and
we all live in harmony now we're all
gravel great to be a gravel rebel space
yeah or just we're all we're all part of
the next yeah and we already are I mean
I think probably we already are that but
I mean I to me I think that whatever is
happening you just have to make it a
good thing like whether or not it is a
good thing or not that's if there is
something great about humans is that
we're capable of alka maizing phenomena
in a way that it doesn't completely
drive us nuts or paralyzes that's any
anything that's happening to you can be
converted into something either that's
going to make you scared
self-destructive rationalize your anger
rationalize your shitty decisions or it
can be used as a thing that completely
quote converts you completely shifts
your method or a way of living and
that's what's beautiful about a human is
there any given moment you can do that
like at any given moment you can shed
your operating system theoretically you
could drop all of the hang-ups all the
weird [ __ ] are you jerking off three
times a day
you could maybe take it down to two
times the den are you drinking every
single night you can't you can stop that
and to me that's like yeah I the future
beings whatever they are I hope one of
the qualities or one of the things they
look back at is like holy [ __ ] those
poor things had no idea how powerful
they were they were sleepwalking when
they could have at any moment connected
to the great truth that divine the the
the glory of all things and could have
theoretically any one of them just one
of them could have converted the entire
planet and up and do an up leveled up
resonance up consciousness utopia but
they all were sleepwalking and then
finally somebody woke up for real and I
don't know maybe it's a I don't know
what that looks like well maybe that
what what looks like is what this is
what this is happening what what is
happening right now with this virus
where everybody's being forced indoors
and forced us to stop work it's a it's a
terrible thing for people financially
but it is in a sense a reset button it's
a real reset button to know that this
shitty job that you hate going to could
go away at any moment because all jobs
could go away in any moment it's a real
wake-up call because even the good jobs
are going away right if you're in San
Francisco you have the best job in the
world guess what you can't even go there
right you might have the best job you're
so [ __ ] pumped to go to work every
day you can't go you can't go so that
can be taken away from you too so if
you're living a [ __ ] life like
recognize that all of this for everybody
could go away right if Yellowstone blows
half the people die right
easily easily maybe more maybe more that
[ __ ] could easily go sure we we
need these little catastrophes sometimes
just to let us understand that the
window of time that we've been existing
in that's been relatively free of
disaster is unique and that's not normal
normal is madness normal is we're in the
middle of a [ __ ] shooting gallery
spending a thousand miles an hour
fireball that's normal and every now and
then ship flies into our atmosphere and
wrecks havoc this is why I love Hollow
Earth theory man you ever get into that
[ __ ] is that for people to get kicked
out of the Flat Earth Society yeah
hollow flatters people look down on
Hollow Earth but hollow earth
hollow hollow earth is like to me my
favorite of them all because to like its
idea is like yeah humans have been on
the planet for a long time and if we
want to go into like the cool idea of
the Atlanteans and advanced
civilizations at some point if you can't
create a way to protect from the meteor
impacts and you're looking to create a
sustaining civilization you're gonna
want to go in there man and so to me
it's such a [ __ ] cool idea that in
the core of the earth is another Sun
that has an advanced civilization that
hasn't been disrupted by the [ __ ] that
happens on the surface of the planet
it turns the earth into a spaceship
inside the spaceship for these advanced
beings and outside the spaceship it's
like a celestial fungus it's like
growing out to the cyst or it's like
another way to put it would be outside
the spaceship as Mad Max like covering
outside the spaceship is just a bunch of
like you know us that are inside the
thing who have basically been completely
disrupted over and over and over again
so they're they have no idea what
history is they have no idea where the
planet came from they don't know
anything and now we've sort of grown out
of control all around the ship and so
this kind of [ __ ] that's happening is
like turning on the windshield wipers
it's like hey man you got humans on you
you know that right man you're like
crawling with them oh [ __ ] wipe them out
get rid of them let's just scrub the
[ __ ] surface do some earthquakes
Yellowstone is just a windshield wiper
for the people who live inside the
planet well you know what humans are man
really a vector for ideas yeah it's
ideas that change everything
the humans just do the work of the ideas
but what we are we're the first thing
that can manipulate our environment that
has ideas we're the first thing with
all these other animals they had
instincts they had ideas in terms of
like trying to figure out the best
patterns to acquire food how to sneak up
on birds yeah but if you think cats have
ideas well guess what they all have the
same [ __ ] idea cats aren't inventing
[ __ ] you know they're not inventing
things there's a specific kind of idea
that's unique to a human being
regardless of the sentient of other
animals ours is unique in that it allows
us to make stuff not just little things
we can make gigantic machines that
travel in the space and all the the wild
creations of human beings all came out
of ideas we think it's all humans but
true we we're the ones that put four but
if you're a thing that wants to get born
you need a host you get that curious ape
to just been trying to figure out better
ways to stab its neighbor with a spear
get that thing and slowly infect it with
ideas ideas of new stuff to make and
then it goes out and does the work for
you and then you take over the earth the
ideas have taken over the earth the
people are just the toys the ideas now
if instead of ideas you set demons I
mean that's that's literally what people
used to think was happening to folks
when they did terrible things they had
bad ideas they acted on those bad ideas
and ancient religions thought of those
ideas like there were demons like these
people were possessed that was a common
thought that someone's possessed by a
demon though hey we are all possessed by
ideas and some possessed by them more
than others like Elon Musk is
particularly haunted he's possessed by
ideas and what does he do
well you look at what he's done he's one
guy that's probably had more of an
impact on our perception of what the
future holds in terms of technology than
any other one individual human being
that is widely known of like he is a
famous human like he is I mean he's
doing Tesla which is the most advanced
electric cars in the world they're
insane yeah then he's doing this [ __ ]
loop thing right the hyper or the the
boring project where he's boring
who's doing the Hyperloop he's doing the
boring project is making tunnels under
LA and Vegas and you're gonna be
shoot through those tunnels going 120
miles an hour then he's making rockets
that shoot up into space
oh and solar power - yeah like what how
was one guys doing all this what's going
on there well that guy's infected by
ideas that guy probably has a huge
receptor and ideas have clung on to him
just like some girls have big tits
some people have crazy parts of their
brain that soaks in ideas there's no
rhyme or reason to why but what what
they are is an antenna for ideas those
ideas come up you're like wow I'm glad I
thought of that and then you go to work
on fracking you gotta work on all kinds
of different crazy things they've
changed the world forever whoever
invented Fukushima right he's like I'm
figuring out how to shut it off when
that time comes we'll figure it out no
one ever does but that person talked
people or that group of people whose
ideas all coincided talk to people into
building a gigantic nuclear furnace that
you can never shut off yeah how crazy is
that that's crazy it's crazy we scan the
skies from meteor impacts but we have no
way to scan human consciousness for some
incoming yes yeah because some ideas
coming in are gonna be great
but there's gonna be a few there are
really bad ideas like you know Hitler he
had an idea yeah it was a bad [ __ ]
idea and the implement that idea was
just floating an astral plane gradually
just shooting towards Hitler's but I did
that ideas fueled by an ecosystem and
let just like you're fueled by nutrients
right human beings are fueled by plants
and fish and animals and vitamins and
all these different things well you're
these ideas are fueled they're fueled by
insecurity and ego and lust and greed
and jealousy and anger and virtue and
love and prosperity and comfort and and
community and all those different
components of human consciousness all
interact with this idea so the idea
becomes like it just hitches a ride and
hitches a ride with all these ideas that
that already exists in your brain and
then with these pre-existing structures
like businesses and warehouses
all these different things that we use
to make stuff and then ship it out then
the idea becomes a thing and then the
idea winds up in the belly of a seagull
because it looks like a fish
whoops sorry you're dead you're dead
seagull you couldn't figure out that
that's a bottle cap not a fish and that
this is this is how things change they
don't just change because of people
we're blaming ourselves and it is
definitely us that's doing the work but
it's all coming out of ideas if we
thought of ideas as a life force instead
of thinking ideas is like something you
own yeah something you hold but even
though you do deserve credit for your
ideas because your discipline to sit
down and try to cultivate these ideas
accelerates the production of those
ideas and exercises the muscle through
which those ideas come through focus and
energy so you deserve credit for it I'm
not is not socialist way of looking at
it but everybody that has an idea that's
really good will tell you it's like it
came out of nowhere
like every great bit that you've ever
had it's like pop a light bulb goes off
and you have this thought and it comes
out of nowhere right that's like most
things did you write that are really
cool they kind of come out of nowhere
yeah you sit there and then also you
think of things and you write them out
they're like they're an idea that you're
wrestling you just catch them and just
catch them weld it man this is this is
why I love collaborating with people
because the more people you collaborate
with you instead of just using your own
brain as the net to catch these ideas
when you have a group of people sharing
whatever the intention may be whether
it's to make like flesh-eating robots or
to cure cancer or whatever then that
becomes this like amazing a solar panel
for like big ideas you know so I mean
this is to me the weirdest thing about
when you're working with a group of
people are collaborating with people if
you know someone's off you will sink to
that level but if you're you know when
you're around funny people you get
funnier yes you know when you're around
like people who can draw you can draw a
little better it's like something about
being in a group sure sure you know what
I'm talking about
yeah that works that way with martial
arts really works it yep it works that
way with pool when you watch people play
pulled it a really good you could play
better if you're a player like you see
someone play really good you realize
like things that they do and you see
them and you emulate them and then you
could do it we feed off of each other in
that respect I think that's a big
argument for the Comedy Store so good
because there's so many comics there and
we all feed off each other that's right
if you're going on after Jeselnik you're
like [ __ ] that guy's so good that's so
funny and they like it elevates
everybody that's right
if you're there with D'Elia or Joey or
you or you know Sebastian like [ __ ] man
how am I so lucky Ali Wong and Whitney
yeah and Eliza like you're working with
some of the best people in the country
the people that are killing it all over
the country one of them hurt and Tom and
me I keep going on and on and on and
then they're helping you punch up jokes
yeah I got stage what is my favorite
memories they're in Jeff Garlin and
Whitney Cummings are helping me punch up
a joke and I'm sitting I'm just thinking
like what the [ __ ] this is like Hogwarts
how am I getting how are these two
people who are brilliantly funny and you
know nothing you refine some like
ridiculous just dumb joke do you ever
still have imposter syndrome yeah yeah
me too
everybody does I think that's powerful
yeah I don't get it as much anymore but
it still do it stick you'll early used
to get it with famous people yeah no
yeah I get it I was around famous people
I always felt weird like oh my god I'm
not supposed to be around these people
they're too famous the real famous I'm
just fake famous right you know I did
it's a weird insecurity that pops up but
I think for you it's like you know when
we first became friends you were the guy
who answered the phone at the store yeah
and that's really do those crazy
conversations that you and I had without
calling to give my avails we would talk
to the phone for a [ __ ] hour
sometimes I know about wacky [ __ ] but
that those sort of those kind of
interactions that you have with people
that they shape like they shape they
shape what you are that's right you know
and the more people that you have in
your life that are like that that are
interesting that you like you feed off
and you you can have good ideas we could
we could engineer a society that's way
better that doesn't have all the
pitfalls but we off to pull our own
weight
it's like there's there's a problem in
this society where there's there's
siphoning off of money right there's
massive moving and exchanging of money
and some weird way with like banks and
mutual funds all that stuff's like what
are you guys doing like what is how how
are you so rich it's moving money around
like there that's sort of that system
since they run the financial system that
sort of idea of how everything gets
distributed its kind of hijacked because
they kind of run the system we all are
in the system and we all clearly benefit
from the system it's the best system we
know of but still there's some people
that are doing some wacky things with
the system and they have giant yachts
yeah they don't fifty buildings but if
that wasn't the case if it was a more
fair distribution meaning not not
meaning that you shouldn't be rewarded
for your work but that you can't just
kind of hijack money the way bankers can
right you can't just kind of do this
there's so so so much weirdness about
using money to make money and that's all
you do you're moving money around what
are you doing you don't even have a real
job right I mean you have a real job
like you're not making a thing right
you're not writing a thing you know
you're not teaching a thing you know
you're just moving monies around you
deciding this company sucks I'm gonna
[ __ ] bet on this one like whoa and
you're those the people oftentimes that
have the most exorbitant amounts of
money that it's not saying that they
shouldn't have a lot of money they
figured something out I'm saying that
the system as it exists that it would
allow someone to make that much [ __ ]
money from things is a little crazy
crazy it's a little crazy it's not
saying you shouldn't be able to get
ahead I'm not saying you shouldn't be
able to kick ass not saying you
shouldn't be able to acquire an
extraordinary amount of wealth are you
saying I don't know if that makes sense
to keep that sort of banking system to
keep in place the way it is to keep the
stock market in place let's what is it
well it's based on confidence like what
are they doing they're moving numbers
around they're buying and selling and
things are getting oh it's not worth as
much anymore because this happened oh my
god sell sell sell a lot of people are
shorting it what you gonna do I'm gonna
buy these [ __ ] idiots they're wrong
apples coming back yeah
he's moving money around like wow what a
wacky way to run an economy yeah man
bunch of [ __ ] pill heads yeah so I
quit why I used to know these [ __ ]
kids from high school that uh one on one
guy that I delivered newspapers with
then went on to become a stockbroker
that guy was always doing coke really so
he was a madman he was a madman yeah I
just love the pictures on the stock
exchange whenever it's crashing war
those [ __ ] dudes like it always cuts
to like the guy whose tires kind of
pulled down he's like who are they what
are they what is that I don't know but
until my friend who was a wild man
became a stockbroker I didn't think of
stockbrokers like that I thought
stockbrokers were like super nerd genius
guys that are figuring things out and
counting and selling the pensions all
the markets and moving I didn't know
there were animals like stop what stock
market guys are [ __ ] savages right
and then the wolf of Wall Street came
along people like what well yeah that's
like my friend piece of the type of
people that are like they have a big
impact on the stock market yeah people
like that [ __ ] that crazy [ __ ]
that went to jail what the [ __ ] his
name
Madoff Bernie Madoff yeah people like
that guy yeah like what the [ __ ] man you
just lying to people yeah you already
you weren't even investing anything now
oh my god like those type of crazy
[ __ ] there's so many of those in
finance it's a mean there's great people
in finance don't get me wrong there's
people that follow the rules there's
people that are wonderful human beings
that also exists in that chaotic world
but it also attracts a lot of [ __ ]
sociopaths
yeah well that's nice isn't that the
idea is that that but like there's the
sociopath personality type is gonna do
better in certain industries yeah
because you gotta be cutthroat yeah
you've got to be yeah you just have to
look at other people as being things you
manipulate yeah dude um man I feel like
a dick can I show you this thing for my
show okay cool you know it was part of
the thing I know you
play you know that kind of like we spark
up one more time before we see it yeah
yeah not gonna touch that no all the
people are like he's handle this mask
wrong he's already I know it doesn't
work I've got a beard that doesn't work
anyway man
yeah there's a lot of people out there
that will critique your technique and
lighting joints really all right
critique everything I think I have one
of the best joint lighting techniques
and I think my problem is listening to
them the problems nothing I'm saying it
the problem is if you like tune into all
the stuff that Chappell's got it right
he doesn't do anything
he's got no no social media at all man's
a genius you don't want to get
contaminated he's just got it locked in
to what he's doing just constantly doing
shows he was doing shows pretty late up
until the the cancellation I did I
forget the last day I did a show man I
think it was uh I think it was mmm I
don't remember but by Friday everything
was canceled by Friday we were like we
can't do this yeah I remember talking to
you about that man I was [ __ ] weird
was weird Comedy Store shut down and
that's like yeah we but it had to it had
to and for everybody that's skeptical
it's really about old folks and folks
that are immune compromised I mean if
you look at a dress elbow on his Twitter
page that guy first of all that guy's a
stud I mean that guy had a lot respect
for that guy it's not only is a badass
actor but he also had a real muy Thai
fight he had a real amateur Muay Thai
fighters training boy tiny got anyway as
a [ __ ] huge movie star and it's a
real fight if you watch it they're
really fighting really yes yeah it's fun
movie is this not a movie I don't know
what he trained he trained it probably
for he was in James Bond right wasn't he
it's pretty son [ __ ] ton of movies he's
definitely done movies where he had to
[ __ ] people up so he probably trained
martial arts for that or maybe he just
enjoyed doing it but he could really got
into muy Thai and he actually had a
fight and he looked good he looked good
he looked like a really good amateur
and he he fought hard it was a real
battle between this other guy but he has
it and he's been doing these videos
updating and talking to people on his
Twitter and he seems fine he seems fun
but he's really healthy he's a robust or
a healthy well-kept man he takes care of
himself yeah same same as a lot of these
NBA players that I would supposedly
habbit a lot of them are asymptomatic
it's not we're not worried about them
we're old people we're worried about
people that are overweight people that
smoke cigarettes that's but this is a
wake-up call to a way worse disease like
if this was the avian flu if this was if
this was something that kill 60% of the
people like you know there's an article
in the Atlantic about this I think it's
this is where I found that the avian flu
killed like it was like 60% the one that
they killed all the chickens in the
early 2000s it was 60% fatality rate so
if you got it see it was more likely to
kill you than not kill you
all right yeah and they got rid of that
one pretty quick but that kind of one is
what we got to be really worried about
this one we have to be worried about for
our older folks and our folks that
aren't doing well but it's a good
wake-up call it's good look no one
responded perfectly no one in terms of
no cities no countries no one did but
everybody got caught off guard
you have to realize everybody got caught
off guard we didn't know the only way
they really know that something like
this is gonna happen is that that it
happens and then there has to be a
response so now we're gonna get better
at figuring out what to do so my hope is
that we get through this and then it
makes us a little nicer to each other
and then we also realize okay we have to
have a plan in place in case a really
bad one happens and we have to figure
out what steps can be done to make sure
that it doesn't happen again right yeah
man I mean this is that is definitely
what I mean if we needed something like
this I wish it wasn't something that is
gonna kill a lot of people's
grandparents and I wish it was something
something a little less but damn you're
totally right man because it's been a
long time since we've had to as a planet
deal with a problem at this level and
it's it's teaching us that there is a
global civilization is teaching us that
we are in our
connected and it's definitely inviting
us to reprioritize our lives man because
holy [ __ ] and there's consequences to
living in a way that you don't feel are
healthy or ethical right like one of the
reasons why they have those ag-gag laws
we're not allowed to film factory farms
it's because people would find it
horrific right and that would be bad for
business well that's not how we're
supposed to look at it see that is
that's that's a symptom of terrible
thinking it's supposed to be the
opposite way we're supposed to make it
so that it's not horrific to look at
right we're supposed to make it so that
it's not this terrible thing now that's
the difference between doing things that
are that feel natural and doing things
that are horrific and the horrific ones
are the ones where all the diseases are
coming from if you think about these
farming operations like so just like
let's just think about these wet markets
when you got all these animals in the
open air piled on top of each other dead
animals laying on a plate dead animals
laying on a table some late stretched
out on the floor and you have them all
over the place you're going to have
problems there's going to be air and
heat and bacterias gonna mix with each
other and then it creates things that's
what happened with the avian flu that
happened in in animal agriculture swine
flu same thing these [ __ ] flus these
horrible bugs a lot of them come from
animals you don't think it was a
bioweapon no I don't think so I don't
think so I think the real fear if you
talk to all the experts the real fear is
an actual known thing jumping from
animal to human we talk insist yeah when
we were at the CDC forget it I'll never
forget it
Jarius [ __ ] interview ever oh not
just that show just devote all time
sitting with that I wish I could
remember his name the guy who ran this
is the head of the place didn't we have
some crazy flight - we flew in and we
didn't have any sleep something we
missed a flight because we got stoned
and we talked at the airport and we
talked for like a [ __ ] hour and a
half and then suddenly were like oh [ __ ]
our flight that's right we didn't just
miss it by like five minutes either we
missed it by like 20-30 minutes and
we're at the airport and it was empty at
the airport and we're like Oh
we there's we have to tape this show
tomorrow you remember yeah so we had a
fly a different flight and we like
barely got an hour sleep right I think
there I think one of us might have had
some magoffin all oh that's right
we took that stuff yeah that stuff if
you've never liked new Vigil if you've
never had or provigil or new vigil I
think they're real similar I don't
remember which one are you used and
provigil is what I used no new vigil
that's what I used definitely you know
the new one and it uh it doesn't it's
not speed now but it definitely gives
you energy and it keeps you awake in the
weirdest way it's like but you're making
it in a great agreement like okay here's
my agreement I want to stay up but I
promise get sleep from now on I'll get
sleep the next day I'm not gonna keep
using this there's not something I'm
gonna keep using and stay up all the
time no no that's what you go crazy but
that's you can use it for that
like if you're a real crazy product I
know some people that use that [ __ ] for
writing they're right on that chair and
they feel like without it they don't
feel like they have any energy yeah man
I mean that's the trap of all those
things any kind anything that's any kind
of nootropics gonna do that man it's
like but also I think some people from
the sleep deprivation that's where they
become antennas for the good ideas you
know they like oh yeah it's like fevered
state of not sleeping for days at a time
and go literally insane and somewhere in
there they write really good stuff
that's what the you know news radio the
staff at Newsradio they used to do that
on purpose
possums Paul Sims brilliant guy the guy
who created news radio and he thought it
would be a good idea to have a writing
staff filled with a bunch of psychos who
were willing to play video games and
stay up to 4 o'clock in the morning
every night it was like this mad
vagabond crew of writers that he had
assembled and they would play video
games and just talk [ __ ] and then they
would start writing at like 2:00 a.m.
sometimes but they would come up with
these amazing scripts cuz and the
scripts were so ridiculous some of them
were so ridiculous and it's because they
were delirious when they were writing
them
they were just instead of doing drugs
they were doing the drug of just staying
awake dude
this is for me I've just I started doing
about six months ago a little longer
waking up at 4 a.m.
regardless of when I went to sleep I was
having some insomnia and so I started I
realized like [ __ ] I'll just like wake
up when I wake up and then waking up 4
a.m. if you have insomnia that is going
to cure your [ __ ] insomnia because
when night time rolls around you're
exhausted
but not only that 4 a.m. is like the
great time for writing weird [ __ ] oh yes
you're still half asleep and the stuff
you write is it's like really feels like
you're tripping you know especially
waking up before him and then like
eating weed I was doing that so you do
eat weed first and then start writing
yeah well no what my system before the
[ __ ] apocalypse was and again I
wasn't doing this every day but I did do
it for a stretch because I got into
David Goggins but 4 a.m.
eat we'd go to the gym and because I was
at the gym because I was at the gym
that's where I would write you were
there that early well no because it
would open it I got there once before
the gym opened must have photo Salvage
no I didn't do because what happened was
I got to the gym and then I did I felt
pretty [ __ ] cool but then I went into
the car and I'd like 30 minutes to blow
and I'm [ __ ] stoned man and I'm
sitting there baked and I'm like a
bucket I'll just like sit sit in the car
and try to meditate this is in the
parking garage of the goddamn Hollywood
equinox now let me tell you something
man that area of Hollywood is already
[ __ ] weird but I'm sitting there with
my eyes closed I'm kind of tripping I
feel like I'm half asleep half awake I
look over there are two dudes creeping
up to my car window creeping up there
and I'm like what the [ __ ]
I was sitting in the passenger side I
jumped to the driver's side started the
car I'm driving through the parking
garage stoned these two weirdos were
definitely walking up to my car I'm like
tripping like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] I'm not gonna work out and so I
I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm gonna let
these two like four am weird vampires
stop me from working out so I Drive back
in one of them's like leaning up against
a pillar like just staring at me creepy
dude these people look like The Lost
Boys or something you're probably
preying on the cars of people that go to
work out probably looking for a car to
break into right and that's what like 4
a.m. people that are out on meth and
they know that this [ __ ] like to go
to the gym and leave their [ __ ] in their
car right there you go
there you go it was terrifying but you
know it those that's what you get at 4
or 5 4 to 5 a.m. is you get math heads
and you get people who are trying to
improve their lives it's the funniest
mix of people you get people who are
like I'm not gonna waste [ __ ] second
I'm gonna get up early I'm gonna
exercise I'm gonna write because that's
when like I mean this is a woooow idea
feel free to light that [ __ ] again but
like there's there's an idea of prana
which is like energy and and there's
more energy in the morning than there is
at night so if you get up at 4 you're
getting like the the purest most amount
of this [ __ ] so that's why a lot of
people meditate it really early while I
like a lot of monks get up really early
is because like it's a oh no it's just a
very it's the most psychedelic time way
more psychedelic than like midnight yeah
it has you're having your certain some
form of control over your life that
especially right that you're exerting
discipline like my friend Jocko he says
discipline equals freedom he gets up
every morning at 4:30
there you go and he puts a photo of his
watch on Instagram and usually it says
go time or something like those lines
get after it every [ __ ] day I go it's
the best driving I mean before the
pandemic when there was still traffic
driving around at 4:00 a.m. you're awake
mmm you're half asleep also I think it's
easier to work out that early cuz you're
but whatever part of you resist that
[ __ ] is just like weak got to be careful
lifting weights in the morning you
really want to warm up because you can
injure yourself a little easier
sometimes you know that yeah cuz you
just sleep it all night you're kind of
stay
if you want to warm everything up get
everything going they say that people
lifting weights it's not the best idea
to lift like your personal record
deadlifts and [ __ ] like that first thing
in the morning it's just yeah you gotta
eat your body up it makes sense
your body's more heated up by the end of
the day by the end of the day you lose
you've been walking around doing stuff
looking for it you workout getting
pumped and then you can go in there and
workout I used to love jiu-jitsu class
at 8:30 p.m. for me that was perfect
because jiu-jitsu it was like 8:00 at
8:30 it's like man I got plenty energy
I'm eating all day you know it's like
I'm not tired yet like going to bed
tired but you know cuz back then I was
going to bed it like 2 o'clock in the
morning every every night anyway but it
was like 8:30 was perfect done by 10:00
I'd hit the comedy store be on stage at
11:00 that's crazy I don't like working
out at night I loved it loved it it's
great because you're you have energy but
you but it's easy to do because you wake
up at noon you know and just [ __ ]
stumble out of bed do whatever [ __ ]
you have to do that day if I my day off
from you know doing stand-up at night
yeah it's easy you just eat and hang out
and then eventually work out but if you
get up in the morning get a little bit
of a victory yeah a little bit of a
victor just having accomplished that
thing you've gotten up and then next
thing you know you doing chin-ups wrong
maybe you're doing chin-ups you know
doing champs well I could do like to do
look done due to what I was what more
what it would be is like me sitting on
those nice couches at Equinox writing
because like I said workout yeah I would
procrastinate and that's what I realized
it's like I do my best writing at the
gym that's hilarious so do you bring a
little notebook yeah I just started
bringing my spirit there too right and
then I would just sit and write and
we're hold spend so much time writing
cuz if that part of you that doesn't
want to work out we'd rather write it's
like when you have to write and you find
yourself cleaning mm-hmm it's that you
know you can like sort of convert your
procrastination into something positive
yeah yeah that's interesting then I
would go work out you know but I would
like I was so when I was doing that man
I was getting the best ideas I was just
running on the treadmill stoned if you
know 5:30 or whenever the [ __ ] gym
open and you're always listening to this
like
I started listening to that was when I
was listening in Goggins so I'll be
blasted listening to Goggins running on
the [ __ ] treadmill ik yeah [ __ ] yeah
I'm gonna do an ultra [ __ ] marathon
how about that I'm never gonna go ultra
marathon you listen to him too and he's
aware that people like me are gonna be
hypnotized by him because he's like
don't do what I'm doing you can kill
yourself just exploding no to it how
many people do you think have collapsed
at the gym cuz a david Goggins about
like what 30,000 people yeah for sure
this is probably a lot of blown out
knees out there whoa now [ __ ] the backs
goin biceps that guy will run with his
foot falling off the step book is really
good what's that it's called can't hurt
me yeah Jesus like it's amazing he like
soze's calf muscle back on swig that guy
could like I get like if that guy wanted
to like burrow into an elephant he could
he's a good dude - I like hanging out
with him he might be I've hung out with
him a few times got a dinner a few times
yeah yeah yeah he went to the fights a
couple times he's a good dude he's a fun
guy meme I enjoy him yeah my friend
think he's enlightened he's something
he's something special there's there's a
switch that that guy has that we all
wish we had where he can he can power
through but also he's a beacon of
inspiration like for other people when
David Goggins does the [ __ ] that he does
and and when he has those speeches while
he's running you know he's like
someone's talking it was like 104
degrees outside and he goes why you
running because I'll tell you why I'm
running because you're not [ __ ]
that's why I'm running and you know he's
out there just I mean he's he's
constantly doing it like he's constantly
pushing himself that's what I love me
that's this he's like a servant in that
way he's a servant he's a servant to the
world he's not just like he's really
giving people because like he's put he
post pictures of himself when he was
like sort of fat
all the time and I'm like yeah I'm
showing people like look this is the
possibility at any moment you can do
this at any moment and I love that
because I do I know when I see him like
he's like running through glass he's
running like you know he's like running
through like swarms of mosquitoes and
malarial swamps just to show people look
it doesn't the part of you that's
telling you that you can't do this
because of X in your environment is
probably wrong not all the time but for
sure man a lot of the time wrong a lot
of time and that for a lot of us that's
like so powerful like I've net of all
the self-help books I've listened to I
listened to my audible that's the best
one by far hands down that's the best
one man but cuz it's real it's not from
a guy who really hasn't done anything
that's trying to get you motivated to go
out there and conquer in life it's from
a guy who's actually done some really
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and it's telling you
that you can do it too and that he used
to be weak yeah he's doing something
right now because Cameron Haynes son
Truitt is trying to break Goggins
24-hour chin-up record so Goggins was at
he was like what I think it's like
Cameron Haynes Instagram page see if he
let put the video on his Instagram page
but he was at some ungodly number of
chin-ups what when they were making the
video he's right that break that yeah
he's like I've been doing chin-ups for
nine hours straight like 1500 chin-ups
or something stupid crazy yeah and he
still had all those hours to go so I
think it might even be like a two-day
thing I don't know how many days are
supposed to be doing this but it's um
does he have it in there with Goggins is
there a video of Goggins doing chin-ups
I mean the stories I hope I'm not
releasing any information that shouldn't
get out
is this live again dope out there yeah I
can't find it yeah whatever
anyway you want to see the show he's
doing loves your show so anyway shout
out to try it out shout
to true it good luck true a shout-out to
Goggins I hope I hope they dig battle um
all right this thing Netflix I told him
I said call min it's called the midnight
gospel the midnight gospel with Duncan
Trussell in Pendleton ward the guy made
adventure run this guy
it comes out 4:20 Netflix this has never
been seen they its exclusive for your
show they gave us permission this this
is Joey Diaz is in this and this is a
podcast I did taking off my glasses yeah
this is a podcast I did with Damien
Echols do you know that is he was like
in the group of kids who got accused of
murdering someone in the woods there's a
whole no oh yeah there was like a whole
documentary about him on I think
HBO it's like basically he would this
dude the I had him on my podcast he
wrote a book on magic he practices magic
but Jesus talking he was on he was on
death row and they did a DNA test that
exonerated but he was like about to be
executed he's on death row studying Zen
Buddhism like Zen priest was working
with him to like basically like it you
know prepare him for his death you know
soon as he was badly beaten on death row
he was almost executed then he was
exonerated because of DNA but we did
this interview before the show obviously
and this is just a way that we figured
out to take podcasts and put him in ok
once he gets exonerated does it before
we start those does he get do they have
to pay him I don't know it's a great
question I think maybe part of it that
they may I'm not I don't want to say
because I've no idea I've no idea I
think they guys on death row yeah I mean
it seems like you owe him something well
yeah I would literally innocent yeah I
was an actual innocent person that you
almost killed and the tree made their
life hell yeah I mean eyes are the
torture of knowing you didn't do
something but being accused of that
thing well I know man knowing it's gonna
cost your life didn't really didn't do
it yeah but let's play
you know how in certain Buddhist
traditions yeah
like say Tibetan Buddhism they talk
about what sword they use empowerment
yeah you know it's like a current of
energy yeah it's passed along from
master to student ceremonial magic is
the exact same thing the Knights Templar
started receiving this current whenever
they were over there that's how it makes
its way back to Europe eventually if it
makes its way to the United States
through the Hermetic order of the Golden
Dawn which was the order that Crowley
was a member of before he you know went
off to the OTO you had MacGregor Mathers
Dion fortune the poet WB Yeats all of
these people were members of the Golden
Dawn that's how this current makes its
way to the u.s. one second hey Steve
what the [ __ ] you need to shine that
light my [ __ ] eyes that's how you're
gonna talk to customers I'll just take
my ship full of cats and find another
junk on ship for cats
ah [ __ ] my apologies look at all these
wonderful gifts and gadgets here we got
a fresh print the time slappa elected
some cans and you want that a vintage
Enlil that ain't cheap pal it's gonna be
five cats he's bluffing
I can get it for three watch this three
five fine Steve four and that's my last
offer
alright you take him flakes out of my
Minos mouth but fine for it is send them
over yeah yeah Wow
yeah man it was like it was the craziest
thing working on that show with
Pendleton cuz he's like a like you know
we throw the word genius around but the
guy's an actual genius it was like
really really really cool to get to do
just so I'm sorry to interrupt you but
it's it's oh it's a combination of your
podcast and then some interstitial stuff
they like you that you is like scripted
it's yeah it's like basically my
character is this guy Clancy
who lives in a place called the
chromatic ribbon where people use
multiverse simulators to simulate
universes so that they go inside and
harvest the technology and sell it and
so my character has a malfunctioning
used multiverse simulator that isn't
really working to produce technology and
because it's malfunctioning every single
world in it is going through some kind
of apocalypse
and so my character goes into his
simulator and interviews people and
though in the dying world so that's
basically the idea of the show so he
took podcasts dialogue it's basically
what happens with you know during the
apocalypse what's gonna happen people
are gonna do podcast people are going to
still have conversations so these
conversations we just set them in these
surreal universes where shit's melting
down and you know we're like Clancy
meets these various people and kind of
learns from them
what's crazy is you started this a long
time ago and it's coming to fruition
right when the apocalypse hits I know
dude that's the thing it's like a little
on the nose I mean yeah I mean it's like
it's almost like it's it's almost like
you knew it's almost like you had a type
and then the universe is like this is a
perfect time for duncan [ __ ] to come out
and let's let's coincide it
I mean look just look at how bizarre
your show is yeah strange and then the
fact that it's a hybrid of podcast
conversations and then written stuff so
strange
yeah perfect time for it yeah you know I
think it is a perfect time for it and I
hope like because some of the like every
guest we it was we chose for this they
all had this like really like amazing
thing to say like Eccles in this episode
one of the things he says you know I
asked him like do you feel like you kind
of like were blessed that you ended up
in solitary confinement cuz that's where
he woke up memory started meditating
that's where he started studying magic
that's where he started working on
himself because there was nothing else
to do right any in this when he says
like I feel luckier than some
I was out there right now you are like
completely disconnected because that's
the coolest thing about him is you would
expect a person who'd been on death row
to be bitter he's the sweetest most
genuine wonderful person ever and it's
like whatever went on in the situation
of being on the brink of the abyss where
he's about to get murdered by the state
for something he didn't do something
about that didn't turn him into someone
who was like shell-shocked or angry but
like really turned him into like someone
very compassionate and and I guess
grateful for his life you know and that
to me like it's like he's like the
Goggins of death row I mean if you can
be not bitter after being on death row
for something you didn't do and like
getting physically assaulted you know
just wandering everyday if you were
gonna die if like you can still maintain
an attitude of service or contribution
to society in some way or another then
any of us can any of us can you know
like any of us can and to me that's like
I think that's I hope some of that stuff
trickles out from the show into the
world right now especially man right now
especially when you say he studies magic
what do you mean by that so well he
wrote a great book called high magic
which is I think that's what's called
it's a fantastic book on magic is really
the wrong word for there's a entire like
mythos or religion that got sort of
wiped out by Terence Mckenna talks about
it a lot I got kind of wiped out by I
get you know superstition so witchcraft
is we understand it now because of
Hollywood is like you know ladies riding
around on brooms and [ __ ] but it just
used to be midwifery it used to be like
healing women who would like to live her
babies and stuff really and but these
these were all connected to they're all
had pagan roots and and so essentially
you you can follow back this branch of
data that some people say started in
Sumeria or Egypt
ways of meditating ways of connecting
with the universe that are ritualistic
in nature but seem mysterious to us
because even though like if you want to
see what it looks like just look at a
Catholic Mass you're looking at a
ceremony it's fear gee I guess you'd
call it that is a magical ceremony where
bread gets converted into the flesh of a
God that you eat so that's a your watch
they're all wearing robes they're
burning incense so that is magic that's
what ceremonial magic looks like it's
nondifferent from ceremonial magic
someone in the Catholic Church might
tell you this isn't magic this is me
praying to the infinite and asking for
forgiveness that's magic
you're connecting with a divine
intelligence you're hoping from your
connection with the divine intelligence
to produce some change in your own
psychology in your own life and maybe
create good fortune or whatever it is
you're praying for healing whatever it
may be that's magic so magic is that and
that it's I'm not saying the catholic
catholicism wouldn't necessarily be
considered a branch of magic i mean one
of the things he said in this interview
is like if the bible is one of the most
powerful magical grimoires there is I
mean you read that [ __ ] if you really
look in it there's all kinds of bizarre
stuff that doesn't seem to make it onto
a Christian radio
look what well like when in the book of
Genesis it's why are they saying why do
they refer to themselves as a plurality
when God's talking it's not like if when
they're saying like why do we throw Adam
and Eve out of the garden it's we if we
don't do something about this they will
become like us we there's a plurality
that's being mentioned there hmm and so
what is that plurality so throughout the
Bible there's mentions of angels the
Book of Ezekiel the famous one that
ufo-ologists go to is there's all these
contacts with angels a hyperdimensional
beings that have some data set they want
to bring to the world
quite often depending on what book
you're in at some terrifying prophecy
about the end of the world that's kind
but sometimes it's you know some message
of hope or some message of healing
so you could say magic is a
non-christian oriented method for
connecting with those various entities
using ritual that's one branch of it now
I'm not saying by the way these beings
exist or don't exist but you could say
if you wanted to get like
psychologically you could say yeah we
have buried inside of us bit archetypes
bits of the collective that are buried
deep inside of us and that there are
ways to connect to these little
fragments of the collective mind and you
know many people know have their own
method for doing that one of the methods
to do that might be doing a ritual and
and for a moment allowing yourself to
imagine that you're trying to talk to an
extra dimensional beam Aleister Crowley
famously did one of these rituals and
contacted a god what was I can't really
that being was called but it looks like
a gray alien this is before people were
talking about gray aliens we've looked
at it raw he draws a drawing of it yeah
and it looks like a gray alien it's like
your was ooze it's like the 1800s
Aleister Crowley was in the 1800s yeah
1890 pulling at your ghillie suit you
remind me of a drunk overweight girl
with large breasts it keeps adjusting
her halter top
like you're in Florida outside drinking
it's a motel
I'm gonna leave you Clarence I'm tired
of your [ __ ]
I told them with a cigarette in hand Wow
look at that drawing by Aleister Crowley
yeah that doesn't your grey alien yeah
man and he likes what we're gonna look
like man let's cut the [ __ ] right that's
we're gonna look like right when you
when you see people that are hairy and
and and brutish you we think of them as
being like closer to prehistoric man
right yeah I see a guy covered in hair
he looks more like a beast
yeah and when we see people that are
thinner and more slender they become
more more a gentle version of people and
we associate that oftentimes of
intelligence we associate directly
associated intelligence with frailty
right we all do that when you see some
some super genius guy usually they're
frail occasionally they're badasses but
there's a lot of those super genius guys
that couldn't fight their way out of a
wet paper bag right well Hawking's the
ultimate example because his body
literally failed him while he was coming
up with his greatest discoveries yeah so
this is this our future never big heads
we're gonna [ __ ] CRISPR your way into
a head that lets you live in any
dimension you want at any time you
transport yourself from one planet to
the other we imagine what we've done
with our stupid monkey brains now
imagine it was a hundred and fifty
percent larger one hundred and fifty
percent more brain and then incorporated
all sorts of [ __ ] electronics so lets
you interface with space-time around you
and all kinds of other wacky ways of
communicating we couldn't even possibly
imagine now just like people from the
eighteen hundreds couldn't have ever
possibly imagined cellphones right and
this is the idea is like okay we're
gonna go there and then when we get
there the way we understand space-time
is going to be different than the way we
understand it now yeah
so what that means is theoretically you
could connect or communicate with a
being that is outside of space-time
which is a future version of us right
now using like various methods DMT being
one of the big ones on the planet right
now but all
so using other methods that they're a
little bit more precise because with DMT
it's kind of like you're not really
putting in GPS coordinates necessarily
some people do it with intention like a
shaman will do it like with intention
and can like you know my excuse me can
you give me another Bloody Mary I told
you Clarence
I'll [ __ ] leave you cigarette in your
hand flip-flops on I will [ __ ] leave
you yeah I'm out of here
Clarence is over there with Miller Lite
you ain't going nowhere just stop just
[ __ ] stop you always do this gets
drunk says she's leaving imma [ __ ]
[ __ ] leave you son of a [ __ ] I'm
putting on my ghillie suit and going
down to Tampa you son of a [ __ ] I'm
gonna visit my family in Clearwater I'm
out of here Clarence it's over anyway
yeah maybe you can connect through time
and space to these things that are
already here
like our understanding of time and space
we're locked in man but like so magick
is like ridiculous on one level as it
absolutely sounds and is on one level on
another level is at the very least a
creative technique so that you can sort
of summon a dream state while you're
awake with the intent of causing some
change in the world around you using for
a lot of people what would be considered
a non-standard way well just in terms of
your perception of how you view the
world you can alter that pretty
radically I mean from someone who has an
amazingly positive perception versus
someone has an amazingly negative
perception you look at the results right
over overwhelming benefit of being a
positive person overwhelming there's
something to thoughts and ideas that
propel you in a good way and for having
a good architecture forget having a good
philosophy having a good operating
manual for how you view the world and
how you act and behave part of that so
you getting up at 4 o'clock in the
morning that's what that is you're like
enforcing your ability to sort of
dictate the positive aspects of your
future you're you're deciding to take
action you're strengthening your bond
with with the way you interface with
current reality and I was doing it rich
I mean not rigid
stop what the [ __ ] out Christmas hmm God
listen man if you want to meet me here
I'll meet you here we could do some 580
sessions I love that man I mean yeah I
would love let's do it I'm 100% down
yeah come down here we'll get pump will
put Slayer on and [ __ ] walk I'm gone
what else do we have to do but else we
have to do is be a great thing
look I'll tell you one thing though I am
enjoying not going out I'm enjoying it
I'm enjoying being home most of the day
other than the type of days I do podcast
but not doing shows at night gives you
so much more energy yeah oh my god it's
crazy you like can you feel like rested
feel good I [ __ ] love it man it's I
get to be with my son more it's like
really nice the place we just moved into
who ever lived there before us had a
flourishing garden so I've just been
going out back pulling spinach out of
the ground and like I know man left you
food they left this food that's pretty
dope
yeah that's such a such a smart thing if
you have a yard I get mad at myself for
not having a garden looking on the
garden right now I've had one in the
past but I love a garden right now yeah
I think it's a like especially now we
should realize like man you should have
food in a freezer somewhere and you
should have a garden that's right and a
gun but I got some milk for you do you
really
oh yeah yeah that would be very grateful
you know I have I bought a box of these
insulated freezer bags for people to
thank you yeah it's such a that's a nice
aspect of being a hunter because you
have you get hundreds of pounds of meat
from one animal so you can share that
with a lot of people it's really it's a
feel it makes me feel real good that I'm
giving some to people then they send me
pictures of cooked food like Tom Popeye
just sent me this picture really Stros
that he cooked yeah he's an elk fiend
now Tom probably eats a shitload of elk
well I don't think I've ever had help
you'd love it it's delicious
I'm gonna give you a bunch of different
kinds but the sausage is the easiest to
make cool so easy you just pan fry it
you can do it in butter I prefer to do
it in beef tallow I just see her two
beef towel my favorite way to do it is I
get to get it to like a medium medium
temperature and then I put tomato sauce
in with Ellis simmer the tomato sauce
man you're the best that's gonna be so
cool for my kid to have apocalyptic
rogen health it's gonna be the best to
bring back ELQ during a pandemic to your
family well that's an L I mean that's an
L that died from a shot from a bow and
arrow you know I mean that's a there's
something about that to me that there's
there's more power to the the meat it's
like I not more power in that it's like
a powerful thing more power in that like
I know what that animal was that animals
a wild beast evading predators and me a
stupid doughy human being managed to
sneak into range where I could hit it
and kill it in one shot with a bow and
arrow I even have a video of it that my
friend cam Haynes took so I have this
animal that dropped and then we took it
apart and butchered it and now I eat it
when I eat it I think of what that
animal was I animal lived a majestic
life and if I didn't take it out it
would have gotten taken out by mountain
lions or bears or it would have froze to
death in the winter sometimes that
happens their teeth get ground down and
there was an older male - which is what
you want to get because those are the
ones that have passed their DNA down so
there's a story to that meat and there's
a connection to that meat and there's no
risk from that meat but when you're when
you're thinking about the risk to
society of like these kind of diseases
that happen through agriculture I think
one of the reasons why that is is
because it's not natural ever for
animals to be stuffed together like that
so when it is nature's just like [ __ ]
you for breaking the rules and then
these viruses start spreading it's
almost like that's what it is for being
unnatural because that those kind of
diseases don't exist that much in
animals in nature they do sometimes like
brucellosis like some Buffalo have
brucellosis it's a bad disease that
cattle can get and then it can infect
the cattle and sometimes elk have it -
if there's a few diseases like animals
always have diseases but it seems like
those ones that jump to people the vast
majority of them have come from us
treating animals in a very unnatural way
that's true but dude I don't mean to get
organs
territorial here but isn't it a little
weird that Wuhan is where that virology
Laboratory was it is yeah I mean like I
don't know to me there gets weird but
it's also weird that there's bats laying
on the floor there good point
that's weird too and we know for a fact
that diseases jump from date they're
tracing these things this is what's
[ __ ] up
Michel osterholm who was on who was the
expert in infectious diseases viruses
and stuff like that
he was explaining to us how they know
certain diseases are morphing and
they're changing they become more and
more human-like and they were talking
about this actually this one that deer
get that's called CWD and it's called
chronic wasting disease and it's first
discovered that my friend Doug Durand
sent me a synopsis of when they first
discovered it but I believe it existed
in like the 1980s cuz when they first
started seeing it in animals but it was
like a mule deer here an animal there
but now it's infected like a giant
population of deer in the Midwest and
they don't really have a cure for it
it's fatal a hundred percent of the time
and it hasn't made the jump to people
but it could well and they're scared and
my colostrum was saying is basically
these things are morphing all the time
they're becoming more and more
human-like they're becoming more and
more like something that can invade a
human host see that that's terrible
terrifying terrifying and I think
there's a battle constantly going on
between these things that hog up too
much resources and take up too much of a
population slice like humans we're on
every goddamn Rock everywhere and nature
tries to throw curve balls out yeah I
mean that's what nature does nature's
like what are you doing you living in
your own [ __ ] oh great here's the plague
you know like that's what's happened
throughout history with whether it was
with poor sanitation or whether it was
you know animal agriculture whatever the
[ __ ] it is people have caught weird
diseases throughout time whether it's
different animals could bite you and
give you a bola you know that kind of
[ __ ] these I mean these weird diseases
have existed forever and they're
basically the same as like viral
Panthers right
what's a panther a Panthers dad to make
sure it's not too many deer yeah the
Panther is the [ __ ] cleanup crew
because if it wasn't for that there
would be [ __ ] deer everywhere you're
from North Carolina yeah you know what
it's like in a country it's crazy
sometimes
because North Carolina doesn't have any
mountain lions North Carolina has no any
wolves so I maybe they have a little bit
of wolves but not not a lot right they
got some bears and they got a lot of
deer yeah looking everywhere yeah New
York State they have a terrible
situation with deer in like Long Island
there's parts of Long Island they were
infested with deer and like what are we
doing we can't just shoot him just gonna
go out and shoot they're trying to give
him birth control the thinking about
giving deers birth control yes yes
because there's no animals out there to
eat them so they just keep [ __ ] just
keep [ __ ] and overpopulating did you
read the stand yes
remember that see that was one of the
things he talks about is how is there
going down the highway they would hit
like herds of deer so thick it would
like block the highway because they were
like starting to overpopulate there
because there is no one there to call
the hurt dude I had a gig once when I
was living in New York and it was in
western Massachusetts so Western
Massachusetts if you are in New York
where I was in New Rochelle you could
get there in a few hours so it was like
two and a half three hours or something
like that you get to where this area's
and where the [ __ ] gig was was so
infested with deer I've never seen
anything like it in my life
you're driving down the street and it's
probably it was hot out it was probably
the summer so I was driving down the
street and these things are just jumping
in front of the car left and right I was
like this is nuts
coming home on the highway was
terrifying I got to go 30 miles an hour
on the highway just with my foot
hovering you ready to stomp on the
brakes because these [ __ ] were
just running in front of the highway
I saw a hundred of them I saw him all
over the place I might have seen 200 of
them driving home everywhere you looked
there was [ __ ] deer yeah why cuz
there's no predators it's an imbalance
and eventually something's gonna happen
and one of the things that has happened
is Lyme disease these [ __ ] deer have
spread this terrible disease to so many
people out there through the ticks the
ticks have jumped from the D the D
cuz there's so many of them there's
[ __ ] ticks everywhere because they're
well fed and like some ungodly
percentage these ticks have [ __ ] Lyme
disease right and they jump on people
they give it to people and people get
sick you know and then the people have
to have a reaction to these deer so they
want to go out and slaughter the deer
there's two it's almost like nature is
trying to balance itself out right or is
bad I mean like you know for us the
goddamn kovat 19 is the worst thing
that's happened to people in their
lifetime in the sense like this [ __ ]
we're experiencing right now is
completely unique for kovat 19 I guess
it's the equivalent of humans like
colonizing another planet like that
broken virus just like what it did is
for it's amazing like it finally made
its way out of one biome into another
yeah it pulled it off
whoever was down there mutating somebody
had the great idea to like do whatever
they did I guess it's like to create a
way to connect to those two receptors
what's it called there's like it's like
a it connects to these two anyway I
don't know wouldn't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about it that's okay it's
like but it like what it did is so
spectacular for the virus what's a you
know catastrophe for humans its glory
for the kovat 19 like super organism
that's now sweeping through the human
biome you know yeah and you know what
else it did that's really interesting it
made it so that it doesn't give you any
symptoms and you're still contagious for
days the worst case scenario so you can
just keep spreading it yeah yeah there
was I was reading a friend sent me an
email from Aspen where apparently
there's one Australian tourist a bunch
of Australian tours had it but one guy
refused to quarantine and he went skiing
and went to restaurants rode the bus and
like a it's like a movie it's but it's a
movie right like that's what happens in
a movie there's this new thing going
around and this guy's like [ __ ] that I'm
here to ski yeah he's like I'm here to
ski I'm going to eat I'm going to
restaurant I'm riding the bus [ __ ]
wow what a dick but that's in the movie
that's what happens right there's a guy
who's in the lab and then like you have
to be quarantined in lab and the guy's
like [ __ ] this I'm going outside and he
has a cigarette and
then something bites him and runs off
and then that thing carries it in its
teeth and bite some a person and the
next thing it spreads to people and hugs
and next thing you know it's a [ __ ]
epidemic and it goes through this and
then turns everybody into zombies yeah
right that's 28 days later right was it
a monkey they were working on some sort
of a disease the monkey got out PETA
rage it was like some pee it was an
animal rights group trying to free
monkeys that had an experimental should
have been pumped into them and the
monkeys like attack the people trying to
save them those people instant instantly
turn into zombies and spread through the
planet well I was reading about this
mountain line that tried to attack this
but I think it was a police officer
well someone I forget who that but the
cops had to wind up shooting the
mountain lion but the the mountain lion
had rabies and know how crazy is rabies
it rabies tricks you into biting people
to give him rabies raccoons raccoons are
usually terrified of people they just
run up on you and they got rabies
squirrels rats all sorts of things
they're not scared of you at all they'll
just [ __ ] jack you if they have
rabies they come after you and you're
like what the [ __ ] is going on well that
thing is trying to give you it's disease
it's a zombie movie
and if you don't go to a doctor if you
go to a doctor they can fix it but if
you don't go to a doctor rabies is fatal
it's just straight up fatal there's like
one person ever that survived from
rabies and he probably wishes he didn't
why was he probably her if ik probably I
mean I don't know I mean it's permanent
like no but there's very few cases of
people surviving it's more than 99
percent fatal rabies is a terrible
disease to die from apparently - oh it
looks [ __ ] awful man but there's a
lot of animals that have it and they
want to bite you that's so crazy it
makes normally animals that are afraid
of people it makes them aggressive to
people well I mean dude did you read
that thing about that guy who like knew
he had AIDS and was infecting people on
purpose he was like getting off on like
giving people a like you wonder how much
of that was his decision and how much of
it was some dark mutation where it
started yes because think of like okay I
was trying to spread I know you do this
I do it I've try not to do it as much
but the spreading of bad news
like you hear some bad thing that just
had this person died this catastrophe
happened you get on the phone and call
somewhere like hey did you hear and
there's this weird rush and like he's
spreading the bad news you're kind of
getting off on it
so in the same way your idea swarm
concept it's the same thing with bad
news you you become a carrier for the
darkness and so you call it now I'm not
saying don't tell people and powerful
shit's going on but sometimes I notice
I'll go through periods where all I'm
doing is telling people about [ __ ] they
should be afraid of yeah you know
spreading and usually the way you do it
is through some story about what's
happening in the world that's really a
form of contagion you know and then that
spreads and spreads and spreads and
spreads and then everyone's freaked the
[ __ ] out and who knows man maybe that
creates the condition of sleepiness or
sleepwalking that we need for these
viruses to appear
you know wonder what it is that's so
attractive to us about breaking the news
I don't know did you hear who died I
used to hear what happened in India when
Michael Jackson died and I've made a
point every single one who called me
your Intel I know and they're like jeer
like know what just to get them off to
let them have the moment like holy [ __ ]
really that's a lair Wow no you've got
to be [ __ ] kidding me you're joking
right because it's like that you know
for them I don't know what that feeling
is that's hilarious do it the next time
some awful thing happens like give me
friends the satisfaction oh now they're
gonna hear this podcast true oh man what
is the rush of telling people I don't
know it's probably built into it's right
because it's like a survival thing like
if you were if you were in a community
and you knew a fire is coming you want
to tell people so there's probably some
reward mechanism worst is when someone
told you but they've you forgot they
told you so you try to tell them and
they're like I told you to you my wife
does that to me all the time she's like
I told you dummy Mike
no that's the worst when you get caught
not listening I knew I was just saying
it again yeah pathetic escape from your
lack of failure to myself no I remember
I know I know I know I'm just talking
out loud that is the that's the worst I
don't that had my wife has done that
actually I was like wait well what did I
just say and you're like oh you were
talking about in the baby oh yeah yeah
when people are around each other all
the time they learn another filter each
other out they have to you need your
alone space and sometimes you get it
while you're still there you get it but
why you still there by zoning out yeah
it's got to be present more than you are
doing that that's right that's that
seems to be the key you got a zone man
it's okay to zone like don't get into
some ridiculous
definitely don't beat yourself up for
zoning no well specially as a creative
person I think zoning spacing out
sometimes and just being bored sometimes
where the best ideas come from yeah
because you can sit around and think
about things like today we're never
bored I mean this is a this is a common
complaint about people when they're
talking about one of the consequences
unintended consequences of social media
addiction is that you're never bored and
that being bored is actually probably
not a bad thing because it fills your
head up with ideas you start thinking
about things and occasionally you
thinking about things that are good that
you might not have thought of if you
just staring at people's butts on
Instagram that's right yeah boredom well
that's like the guy I work with you like
with meditations got David Nick turned
what he taught he teaches me about bored
and we it's a Buddhist concept hot
boredom and cool boredom there's two
types of boredom one of them is where
you're like man that's like the
addictive boredom where you're like I'm
gonna get out I gotta get you know I'm
bored but there's a sense of like the
other type of boredom cool boredom
that's more like what you're talking
about which is like just being okay
where you're at in the moment but
admitting to yourself this is boring
like that's one of the things it's
boring like I'm bored right now did you
tube videos are more fun I'm gonna go
see something crazy on YouTube car chase
yeah it's a [ __ ] do you do you do you
ever like go to your phone
when you wake up at night do you do that
is that your go-to like when I wake up
at night you ever wake up at night I do
and I try to go back to sleep I never
just stay up I just go back to sleep
see that's what man I gotta stop doing
it because I'll wake up and the first
thing I do reach over for the phone
start looking at it waiting to get
sleepy again that doesn't make you
sleepy it wakes you up wakes you up
that's not good it stimulates that area
of your brain that gets lit up by
electronics BP EEP EEP EEP EEP it's so
exciting and stimulating next thing you
know you're awake I do that the smoke
pot thing too and then right but
sometimes I do the smoke pot and workout
thing and then it becomes the smoke pot
and right thing just because the the
rush right after you get high is like
those are where the best ideas come from
and like I feel like you got to grab
those [ __ ] while you have them and if
it means postponing your workout for an
hour like that's actually the smart
thing to do it's the the the dumb thing
to do to go through the workout first
because especially if you got high
because those ideas they're coming hard
and fast for like the first part of the
high and you probably won't get them
like that for the rest of the high so
while you go from being straight sober
to the big rush that you get in the
beginning that's when all my best ideas
come from is the big rush which is like
an hour from getting high to an hour
later that's the big rush that's when I
feel like I get the most like where the
[ __ ] did that come from ideas yeah and
the best writing like when I write
things it's like them the cleanest it's
the filled with the most gems there's
more stuff in it and then the other
stuff is like editing it and putting it
apart and taking apart but if you don't
capitalize on that rush I feel like you
only get one of those a day one big
especially like if you if you're sober
and then you get high that one first
high rush of the day that's not doesn't
last that long
and if you keep staying high I don't
think it's the same and then staying
high you sort of settle in right yeah
yeah but the rush of just getting highs
like wow yeah so many ideas if you
wasted that by doing chin-ups you're an
[ __ ] just agree go right right and
then lift afterwards yeah for sure man I
mean this is yeah you've got a harvest
when yeah when it when
when the wheat is blowing you've got a
harvest you can't miss but it's easy to
trick yourself into thinking oh no I've
got to stick to my [ __ ] workout or
whatever the thing is it's not just
working out it's like whatever I think
it's important to prioritize those
moments I mean especially if you're
going with your like with what a lot of
people say which is this the antenna
idea
you're a receiver your signals you're
like steady but not for aliens for ideas
and these are search for
extraterrestrial ideas that's what you
are you're a satellite for that and if
you start getting I mean imagine SETI
imagine someone at SETI doing chin-ups
and suddenly they get like a some signal
from afar star system and he's like I'm
gonna finish my workout before I check
out whether or not we're getting
contacted by aliens that's an [ __ ] if
you're because the real question is
where do your ideas come from exactly
and if you're picking up whatever these
creatures are and you've been blessed
enough to get them yeah you should write
them down the rhythm though it's kind of
like I mean not that I don't like you
got to honor them honor them right yeah
gonna act on them I mean that's why
people that think of the muse like the
concept of the muse that's one of the
more it's a productive way to think of
it like Pressfield writes about it and
press field in the war of art and he's
you know he's a very down-to-earth he's
not a it's not a silly man it's a very
down-to-earth person but his perspective
on the concept of the muse it is it's
very beneficial if you follow it because
his perspective is essentially that you
pay honor to this thing you show up and
you do the work like a professional and
then it responds in turn it comes to you
yeah and then these are what it's like
the we think of an idea even though it's
one of the most important factors in the
entire construction of civilization but
somehow or another we don't think of it
as that we think of people being that
and we are because but we're being used
by ideas I know that sounds crazy
I really do I know it sounds dumb too
but you are you're coming up with these
thoughts and we're thinking of them it's
like random connections that you're
making in your brain which might be it
might be that but it also might be that
ideas are like a life form from another
dimension that's trying to manifest
itself in our current realm and they do
so through getting into people's heads
and the more you call for them the more
they're there for you and the more you
show up and you can call that the muse
you can call that whatever you want
Jules Tesla believed Tesla believes some
he was getting signals from some other
some other some other planet or some
other life-forms he had some weird [ __ ]
that he wrote it's hard to decipher
about what he CV can find that cuz
that's a very interesting thing Jamie's
heaving about what did Tesla like Tesla
had a take on receiving information from
other galaxies he had this take on where
I some some of his inventions were
coming from it's like why it's so some
of the transmissions that he would
receive I mean goddamn it wouldn't have
been amazing to talk to that guy yes
imagine have a Nikola Tesla on the
podcast oh oh who knows man maybe you
still can one day yeah bring him back or
like you create an AI Tesla I think a
lot of people have that feeling and some
of them just don't come out of a closet
so to speak with it because they're
afraid they're gonna get judged you're
ostracize I think a lot of people feel
like they have a direct contact with
some kind of sentience that isn't
embodied inside of them and it's giving
them ideas and they're just terrified to
put it out to the world because it
sounds like you're [ __ ] nuts his
claims of receiving signals from outer
space were proven right a century later
woo hoo during the summer of 1899 Tesla
set up a field laboratory in Colorado
Springs Colorado to pause to the
possibilities of using high-altitude
stations to transmit information and
electric power over long distances 1
July this is not what nothing about this
is about this signal is not like him
getting I went too quickly on ok where
is the signals this is like like radio
signals oh that he was getting radio
signals from other planets
after the ruling out I think this is
about sending after ruling out solar and
terrestrial causes he concluded the
signals must be from another planet yeah
sure and had a vision which is what like
that's it yeah well here it says a 1
July Day why tracting lightning storms
oh so as his actually equipment his
equipment picked up a series of beeps
after ruling out solar and terrestrial
causes he concluded the signals must be
from another planet the following
Christmas in response to the American
Red Cross his request for a prediction
of the greatest scientific achievement
of the coming century Tesla wrote
brethren we have a message from another
world unknown and remote it real it
reads one two three in 1996 scientists
published published a study replicating
Tesla's experiment and showing that the
signal was in fact caused by the moon
low passing through Jupiter's magnetic
field holy [ __ ]
he was picking up a moon passing through
Jupiter's magnetic field yeah but he had
woo ideas - yeah he was in love with the
pigeon he's in love with a pigeon not
just that though he like I think he did
they use in contact with like some kind
of sentient intelligent Eve for sure why
not why wouldn't you think of you that
smart imagine how smart he wasn't
compared to sending like a regular dope
hey mister you want to buy a paper
you know people from back then some
[ __ ] dude
selling papers in the corner and then
but the greatest genius the world's ever
known up to that point yeah
wandering around trying to figure out
how to send electricity through the sky
maybe that's all intelligence is though
man is like having the willingness to
let yourself go crazy enough to believe
you're not the creator of your ideas to
believe that you're an antenna maybe
that's what makes a person intelligent
maybe that's all it takes it that and
discipline well yeah the discipline to
learn all the things that you need to
know to be able to study and actually
implement that technology psyche Tesla
was both things he was a genius and he
was probably some sort of a visionary in
that way like yeah he had like Elon has
he had an extra large magnet for ideas
yeah yeah dude I think anyone can do
that strong as this weed [ __ ] strong
man I'm so glad anytime you give me weed
I'm always forget how strong it is and
every time I gotta be careful we go
high-grade up in this [ __ ] son it's
important to go high-grade I think so
yeah absolutely
what do you think is what do you think
is gonna happen to us do you think we're
gonna get through this in relatively
short order or do you think this is
gonna take five six months call anything
is gonna take the lockdowns are crazy I
can haunt you like San Francisco the
lockdown is crazy three weeks 24 hours
stay off the streets don't go to work
yeah man I think we're probably gonna
look like listen if you go if you want
to hear my like just instinct
which is definitely gonna be wrong I
think it's gonna go it's gonna get
better much faster than we expect I
don't know why I think that I have no
reason to think that if you go by what
they're saying we're looking at like
months and months and months I guess
like if I have to choose between
listening to my own stoned intuition
regarding stuff which fits into my
desires which is I want it to blow over
because I don't want people to get sick
I don't want to live in the apocalypse I
have a son I don't want to run out of
food I don't want things to get back to
normal I want to go around people but if
you look at like unless we're living
unless it's some vast ridiculous
conspiracy I think we're looking at at
least a couple of months man I mean this
is and I'm going by it not a conspiracy
because I think that in because I have a
son now and if I listen to my own
instincts when it comes to [ __ ] for my
kid
I'm gonna be afraid to vaccinate him I'm
gonna be afraid they do things that like
millions and scientific papers have
shown as safe that's good for his health
because I'm gonna get superstitious so I
lean into science it saves my life you
know science kept cancer for spreading
through my body and killing me I'm gonna
trust the scientists right now in self
isolate and try as much as possible to
not spread this [ __ ] and um I think that
that's even if it turns out to be a
panic hysteria whatever at least you
were part of the people who
aren't [ __ ] going out and skiing
during this [ __ ] thing so I think
it's gonna go on longer and I think
while it goes on longer if you have the
ability to limit human contact and to
avoid the superstitious part of yourself
that I've got to that's looking at this
and thinking like come on really I don't
know what you want to be sick I don't
know I don't know it's also a rejection
from change a rejection of change that
you don't have any control over denial
and deny that it's happening because
that's the easiest thing to do if you
deny that it's happening you don't have
to face the fear and if you don't face
the fear well then you put yourself in
danger but really probably I don't know
how old you are out there but you really
who you're putting in danger is
somebody's grandad yes that's the main
thing is like ten people with diseases
people people that are compromised
there's a lot of us that are not that
strong we in you know maybe some people
are recovering from something you know
like talking to Jonathan ward yesterday
and his wife's recovering from cancer
she's going through chemo so like they
want to make sure she doesn't have to
deal with any of this [ __ ] like it's not
exposed to any of it those are the type
of people we have to be really scared of
people that are compromised right but
this is you know this is a [ __ ] up
moment for us but a learning moment I
really hope that this prepares us in
case something really horrible comes
down the pipe and I think I hope it
prepares us for understanding that this
is a possibility
it lets us understand like hey we need
to accept this this is this is how it
goes and if there's some new [ __ ] that
comes on let's act quicker and let's
take care of this quicker and like if
everybody just had a two week off thing
like you know and this was something
that Dana White and Frank Fertitta were
talking about before anyone did it Frank
Fertitta told Dana White he's like why
don't we just have everything shut down
for two weeks just no one go to work no
one do anything two weeks stop the
planes and the way he explained it to me
was like he said pull the band-aid off
of it I'm like that is actually probably
a really good idea well guess what now
that's being forced mandatory forced in
certain cities where they've got bad
outbreaks if they've just done that the
moment it cut the moment it cut loose
just no one goes anywhere for two weeks
let's nip this [ __ ] thing in the bud
yeah if that was
really done there right it really would
I mean if you could really get that to
be implemented at a scale of 350 million
people amazing but you you could you
definitely would have radically slowed
down the pace we weren't ready we
weren't ready well now we know yeah hope
I hope I hope we learned and I hope it
doesn't morph and I hope it doesn't get
more deadly and I hope you know they can
figure out a way to allocate funds to
get more respirators and you know all
that [ __ ] has to be done you can make
your own hand sanitizer yeah I heard
that you just wash your hands with soap
- yeah you know
soap apparently kills it what do you
think are like the three things you
should have it you're a food you should
have water or something that purifies
water whether they're water for water
purification tablets they you could buy
iodine tablets there's like that for you
think the city water it's gonna get
turned out anything can happen anything
can happen you might need to drink water
that you don't want to drink alright you
know that's possible you might drink
puddle water I mean look the reality is
if things go real bad you might have
drink from a lake right okay and that's
what water is you know water we take
water from various sources and they
purify it and you know rain water and
all kinds of [ __ ] that's what we're
drinking on a daily basis we're drinking
this weird processed water yeah the
water you really supposed to be drinking
is the stuff that comes right out of the
ground that's what you're supposed to be
drinking but if you get stuff that's
biologically infected you get stuff that
you no animals have been in it's animal
waste feces and stuff or bacteria or
diseases or anything you can purify that
you can you could take these water
tablets and you drop them in there and
it kills everything it torches the water
so in cases of emergency like
backpackers they'll find out like an elk
wallow and they can drink that water out
of a [ __ ] alcohol oh really yeah
there's a thing called SteriPEN is
another thing that you yeah this
SteriPEN actually uses ultraviolet light
let's say you have a water bottle you
fill it up with like elk piss and you
like wave your thing because you're
trying to stay alive you're out there if
there's no water like if you're on like
a high country desert mule deer hunt and
you can't find any water you gotta take
water wherever you can get it cuz you
don't you're not bringing all your water
up there if you're staying there for 12
days you're hoping you could find creeks
and you might not find a creek and if
you do it might be [ __ ] up there might
be a dead
like [ __ ] like something might have gone
there to die and polluted the water or
beavers might have [ __ ] in it like you
have to have something that kills all
that stuff so that's something that
people should have they should have I
think you should have some sort of a
first-aid kit
bandages things like that disinfectants
antibiotics stuff like that you should
probably have something like that in
case something goes wrong and someone
gets hurt and there's no hospital
available or there's no doctor or you
have to wait in the morning before you
can take someone to a doctor whatever
the [ __ ] the problem is you should have
that you should have batteries that
you've charged right like cell phone get
some backup batteries charged those
[ __ ] right you know if you have a
generator fantastic but some people
can't afford one of them don't have the
room for one they can't have one it's
not feasible if you live in an apartment
yeah but having charged batteries for
phones is very important food and water
food and water are number one right you
want to have dried foods things like
rice and pasta you could store a lot of
it you could eat it's high in calories
you can eat it you know you and doesn't
doesn't take up too much room there's
you know canned things you can keep
forever that's what you want you want
food that you could have like that you
could keep you alive
you know well let me ask you this man
because this is like something I've been
talking to people and myself I've
experienced a little bit I don't know if
you have but what about those of us who
are like kind of secretly freaking out
right now not so secretly yeah how do we
but to me that's like I think one of the
big questions is you know I was talking
to a friend of mine and he was like man
I totally was losing my [ __ ] yesterday
man and like I told I'm like dude me too
everybody yeah but what like how the
[ __ ] are we gonna deal it's just such a
weird form of anxiety I've never had
this kind of anxiety before it's there's
an invisible monster yeah invisible
monster that wants to kill your grandma
yeah you know yeah an invisible monster
that kills upwards the the high levels
like somewhere around 3% of the people
you know and and with old people it's
even worse with people over over 80 I
think it's you know it's really deadly
it's [ __ ] scary man and what's scary
is this is only
one of many that could be coming our way
right and that this happens every you
know X amount of years or something last
one was you know h1n1 and SARS and this
and that and there's always a new one
and just a [ __ ] flu man I didn't you
know I didn't until we were looking into
this I didn't know how many people the
flu killed yeah the flu can kill ninety
thousand people in America every year
yeah I didn't know that did you know
that I knew that so when they say this
is ten times more deadly than the flu
York
holy [ __ ] maybe 15 times more yeah holy
[ __ ] that's a million people that's a
million plus yeah that's scary that's
scary that's scary and then you know
other really horrible diseases that of
devastated populations those are
possible - and new ones are possible Joe
I was asking how do we deal with the
[ __ ] anxiety now I'm feeling you got
to look at it you got to look at it for
what it is this is reality the way to
deal with anxiety is to be prepared as
best you can
except where you are and what you are
and who you are and just live it
reprioritize Azure values you know
that's that's what's gonna be good out
of this nothing nothing good ever comes
from having it too easy right like for
us I think are as a culture having it
too easy was probably a little bit toxic
to us like always eating junk food we're
always eating sugar
that's all we're eating it's okay to eat
cake every now and then we can't just
live off cake well as a culture there's
a lot of what we were dealing with
living off cake you know if you ever
seen that Werner Herzog documentary
happy people life in the taiga it's a
great documentary about these really
nomadic people that live in Siberia and
they're super happy and they live in
these log houses that they build
themselves and show them building these
houses they don't have enough mosquito
repellent they have to make their own
mosquito repellent with like tar and
they grind it up and add stuff to and
then rub it all over their face and
everything and they're super happy they
live up in Siberia dude it's so [ __ ]
cold it's only it's only summer for like
three or four months it's only like nice
out and then the rest is just bitter
brutal cold where the winter
breezes the river solid we can ride a
snowmobile over the river so they use
the river like the highway and they all
have dogs and they run around trapping
and killing animals and living off the
land and catching fish and living off
the fish dude they're so happy what's
[ __ ] up is these people are
encountering life-threatening adversity
every day if you stay outside you will
die you will die just from exposure to
the cold it will kill you it's 50 below
zero outside it will [ __ ] kill you
and because of that they're all like
happy and smiling and laughing and the
documentary just shows like it's weird
we're not we're never happy like this in
a collective group unless we're all
living in this constant state of like
alertness and consequences for inaction
like there's no lazy people there man
everybody does their part you have to
yeah and they're all working and
laughing and they're all making their
own canoes out of boat out of boards
that they're chopping out of logs
they're hollering out these canoes and
stretching them out it's amazing man
they're just always working and they're
always happy it's so weird
that's it that to me I think a lot of
people don't realize that you can work
together with people not for money just
to do Store community and how fun that
is when you find yourself even you know
my wife and I [ __ ] moving and like
I'm packing boxes it's been like
non-stop for the last like four days
like and we've had to like you know it's
there's something in it even though it's
terrifying that really is joyful and
there's is so like feels more alive than
I've thought in a long time I think
that's the thing we've got to tune into
is that if nothing else were alive right
now that's beautiful and yeah maybe
there's just extent maybe we can become
like those people up there I mean I
think that's one of the anytime of
thought that thing happens to you
personally it's a chance
to become a bitter piece of [ __ ] or a
little more angry or a little more tired
or a little more depressed or to become
a hero anything whatever it may be any
bit of phenomena that comes your way as
a person you know anytime I fight like
anytime something's really got to get
done that I've been procrastinating or
any time some shitty unexpected thing
comes my way I have a moment to decide
am I gonna react to this like I always
react the shitty things and like become
negative or dark or get pissed or can I
like react to it in a completely new way
and I think every time you do a new way
is my woogle concept you pop in to a
different part of the multiverse it's a
little better than the one you were in
before and it's like a trajectory you
can go on when I was getting stoned at
the gym it for him I was imagining on
the treadmill that I was running through
the multiverse towards a healthier
version of me that I wasn't getting in
shape I was actually being inhaled into
a more on shape version of me that
already existed that's the kind of [ __ ]
I have to do to get myself to work out
yeah man it's a fun it's fun to do that
you know every single decision is like a
binary do you want to continue doing the
[ __ ] you've been doing over and over
again whatever it may be or do you want
to try a mildly new way and every time
you do that sure is [ __ ] it's not just
you that starts changing you'll notice
like other stuff starts changing too
around you you know things just tend to
generally get better yeah I think
there's there's thoughts that I've had
that are real similar to that where I've
wondered like if if multiverses are real
and they're supposed to be different
versions of you infinite versions all
over the universe why are we assuming
that this is the same every day you wake
up in the same version why are we
assuming that to think about sleep is
you just go away then you come back with
a memory of what life was like before
you went away and you wouldn't notice if
it just slid you
one notch to the right or one knot to
the left into the multiverse there's an
infinite number of Duncan's out there
with ghillie suits and gas masks on yeah
and you just slid over to the right by
letting a little old lady in front of
you and not even complaining when she
was driving 30 miles an hour okay yeah
like it's all right it's just a nice
lady let me just get around her nice and
slow and safe yeah that's it wave to her
hi and the more you do that yeah the
more you do that the more you start
running into other people who are doing
the same thing hmm you start ending up
in that part of the multiverse where
many other people are doing the same
thing yes and eventually you know
theoretically I think eventually through
those series of decisions maybe that's
where you can like that's where all of a
sudden you start realizing like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm in a temple I'm not even in
a in a reality that I thought I was in I
was just like in a deep state of
contemplative meditation yeah and you
know I don't know I mean there's all
kinds of interesting experiments you can
do if you ever heard the term pro neue
pro noia it's the opposite of paranoia
where you think the universe is
conspiring to help you instead of hurt
you that's brilliant
yeah maybe that's what we'll call a
group pronoia pronoia yeah yes yeah
that's perfect yeah yeah we needed a
name that it just came to us pro neue
sounds like a dope band yeah gonna go
see Pro Noi at the stable Center it's
fun if you do that if you really do
imagine that every single thing that's
happening in your life is a grand
conspiracy to help you to advance you to
bring you or another way to put it
do you ever listen I love listen to
Christian radio this guy was talking
about a thing called convection which is
being inhaled into the Christ so when
you start like like a black hole well I
think like the white hole I guess it
would be a black hole gobbling up
planets but you're being like strong
into this into the super intelligence
and you're becoming in like you're being
sort of lifted up into it the thing that
makes the [ __ ] Big Green Egg work
like the thing that sucks smoke up
that's happening to you into the divine
intelligence and as it happens you
imagine you're the one
doing this stuff to get you closer to it
but really it's just your mind playing
tricks on you you have no choice you're
gonna be you're gonna wake up you're
gonna gain realization and and so as
that's happening you kind of you know
like you can quit something you can quit
drinking
you can quit smoking but you kind of
long for it but then sometimes you
notice you just stop doing [ __ ] that was
bad for you because you found a better
way to live and it naturally falls away
right that's convection you're being
drawn into the divine mind as that
happens the [ __ ] that looks like
austerity when you're like further away
begins to actually just be a natural way
that you act you just become naturally
more graceful naturally less inclined to
do shitty things naturally more tuned in
with like 150 year old version of you
you know that that you sort of naturally
and that just happens on its own because
you were being convicted into the Christ
sucked into the Omega Point the divine
yeah mmm we should probably leave on
that so we end up huh yeah that's
perfect wit in right thanks man thank
you four o'clock what how the [ __ ] does
that happen
what right this was a total time-warp
episode you and I always have the
strangest episodes man I really do then
cool you missed four it's almost 4:00
it's 346 normally I would have had to
piss like three times
dung didn't Russell tell everybody when
you show us out thank you Joe April 20th
on Netflix the midnight gospel you can
follow the midnight gospel on Twitter
and Instagram and thanks Pendleton for
making the show with me thanks y'all for
watching it thank you it looks awesome I
can't wait to watch it looks it looks so
Duncan Trussell thank you Joe it's very
you alright we're gonna keep on keepin
on folks stay healthy out there much
love bye how do you snap
oh damn
[Music]